[Musique]
je vous froid un roux de bézieux bonsoir
bon ça nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle thinker
view nous sommes en direct est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
je m'appelle geoffroy des yeux j'ai 59
ans je suis marié j'ai quatre enfants
je suis entrepreneur depuis assez
longtemps depuis l'âge de 33 ans donc ça
fait 26 ans et je suis président du
medef depuis trois ans maintenant cf
medef mouvement des entreprises de
france donc si une organisation qui
rassemble des territoires fin des
départements et des fédérations
professionnelles il ya 170 mille
entreprises adhérentes
ça représente grosso modo peu près 60%
des salariés je suis alors on dit patron
des patrons mais c'est pas la bonne
expression moi je considère que je lui
porte parole
porte parle des patrons des entreprises
combien vous gagnez
alors ça dépend des années comme je suis
entrepreneur donc ça dépend des années
j'ai un salaire de base qui est assez
faible qui est à 60 kg et après nos
remparts on jouera sur scène j'aurais
pas dit faible à ce camp par mois et
puis ça dépend des aînés donc la
dernière s'est affalé dernière sur
l'année 2020 sap a été une bonne année
pour l'économie française n'a pas été
une bonne année pour moi il se tenait ce
sera mieux une chambre une salle ar non
pas une seule à ce que les résultats
2021 je les connais donc voilà donc ce
jeu vidé vide en fait donc je ne dis pas
ça j'évite et 20 % 1 pouces et sa non
l'occurrence j'évite non puisque je paye
ça dépend de mon taux marginal n'ont par
contre je pète pas de cotisations
sociales sur les dividendes et j'ai pas
la protection donc je peux je cotise pas
pour ma retraite avec des livres c'est
quoi un bon patron ça
c'est une bonne question ma mère est un
peu de réflexion
temps ça tombe bien un bon patron c'est
the right man at the right place ça
dépend
la bonne personne à la bonne place je
veux dire vous pouvez être un bon patron
un maman et être le mauvais patrons
après vous avoir raison trop tôt et vous
tromper de stratégie
donc à mon patron c'est quoi c'est
d'abord quelqu'un qui
et qui comprend le business intimement
c'est quelqu'un qui sait vraiment ce
qu'elles sont les drivers de son
business model qu'elles sont ce qu
attend de ses clients et ses dents c'est
quelqu'un qui arrive en mai ses salariés
alors c'est vrai pour 10 personnes et
c'est vrai pour cinquante mille ou cent
mille
et puis à un moment il ya aussi c'est
vrai dans des boîtes à part d'intuition
quoi il parle de talent une part de
génie vision ouais alors le mot vision
ça fait un peu aimant le langage quoi
hein maman moi je moi je considère que
c'est souvent de l'intuition
c'est faire les bons choix et c'est pour
ça que la même personne elle peut être
un moment un bon patron puis un moment
on se trompe et je pas si vous souvenez
de
vivendi en 2000 donc dirigé par
jean-marie messier donc voila vous
souvenez de l'histoire donc il est
éjecté parce qu'il ya trop investi il
voulait ramener les contenus médian avec
en gros les tuyaux face qu'on appelait à
l'époque les tuyaux c'est à dire
internet le téléphone mobile donc les
télécoms et les médias sauf que cette
même stratégie il a été mis en place par
d'autres après avec succès et donc est
ce que c'est un mauvais patrons j'en
sais rien j'ai pas jeter passée
intimement dans la ferme est en tout cas
il a mené une stratégie qui a échoué et
la même stratégie quinze ans plus tard
était a été plutôt réussi un moment un
autre le pouvoir suze com com comme
partout ailleurs vous parliez d'éléments
de langage combien vous payez vous
conseiller en communication ceux qui
sont juste là
bas il y en a foutu dans la cuisine
il y en a un qui est salarié dans
quelles poches soit plus de son salaire
je peux pas vous dire mais enfin il doit
être bien payé il me rappelle le
contraire tout à l'heure mais et après
on doit avoir
howard bêtise
150000 euros de budget de communication
pour les agences medef voilà à peu près
l'ordre de grandeur je dis ça tout de
suite une question internet at il
conscience de la réalité des gens
ordinaires point d'interrogation 8 qui
gagnent que 60000 euros par an
c'est à dire quoi les gens ordinaires
salaire médian en france le ceux qui
gagnent entre malsain c'est dire en gros
le salaire médian les salaires médians
c'est le salaire moyen ya combien de
personnes en france quel pourcentage de
salariés qui gagnent moins de 2000 euros
pendant ben si justement le salaire
médian est à 2300 donc
pas venaient les chiffres exacts 40
pensent à peu près 40%
entre 40 et 50 csap après l ordre de
grandeur alors je pas je suppose que la
question de votre internaute talent et
est ce que j'ai conscience 20 juil j'ai
conscience des chiffres c'est quoi
prendre conscience de la réalité des
gens mais je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire exactement parleront prenez le
métro ça m'arrive mais rarement je
prends mon vélo souvent quand je me
déplace pas perso vous êtes à combien de
temps de travail de combien de temps de
transport
ça dépend à ce qu'il semble bouteille
âge on va dire 30 minutes
donc non mais si le point c'est de dire
que j'ai pas la vie du français moyen
oui j'ai pas la vie du français moyen
comme qu'il vienne me paye pas la vie du
français moyen après est ce que ça veut
dire que je suis complètement hors sol
est ce que ça veut dire que je
m'intéresse pas aux gens je crois pas je
vais acheter mon pain à la boulangerie
donc voilà
je pense pas tellement répondre à cette
question autrement que en disant je veux
je fais des actes du quotidien que tous
les français font et puis un acte je
fais pas bon ben voilà on va on va en
prendre d'autres questions internet un
peu plus tarder ce soit on va parler
géopolitique finances terrorisme cellule
de prospective au medef et tout un tas
de sujets un peu balèze on va parler
aussi
inflation on va parler des salariés on
va parler des ouvriers on va parler de
l'organe de production l'outil de
production l'organe mais le tir ouais
c'est un organe défaut marfaing
et donc voulait commencer par quoi on se
fait un peu de géopolitique on se
commencer par la géopolitique moi j'aime
la géopolitique je pense que c'est ça
alors un sujet important en ce moment
les patrons français du moins les boîtes
françaises se font régulièrement ouvrir
par ce qui est censé être nos à lille et
on se fait écouter on se fait prendre
des marchés on se fait un petit peu
[__] en prison parce que ça convient
pas x ou y
le medef qui fait qu il n cellule de
prospective il est en connexion avec les
services de renseignements pour savoir
un peu ce qui se passe il fait comment
pour voir plus loin que le bout de son
nez parce que le patron a toujours la
tête dans le guidon il ya plusieurs
questions clés sur j'essaie d'y répondre
par rapport aux manceaux bon d'abord on
a le temps ce soir et j'ai bien compris
comment vous dire ça je pense qu'il ya
un depuis trois quatre ans c'est un peu
plus
il ya une espèce de prise de conscience
et une sorte de fin naïveté
qui pendant longtemps n'était pas
l'apanage des entreprises parce que
au fond finalement
certaines mères tout allait bien
certes on était peut-être même pas
certainement etc ou de paix
espionner et s'aimer
au fond cette mondialisation
elle profitait aux entreprises même si
la france est en déficit commercial est
donc
à tord ou à raison il ya une forme de
naïveté bon moi j'ai ce taux que j'ai un
petit passé militaire dont j'ai toujours
été un peu sensible sur ces sujets là
dormi j'étais en fait dans les commandos
de marine fait mon service militaire à
l'époque il y avait cinq militaires
qui ne vous permet pas d ne vous avez
fait des noeuds sur votre père est
pourquoi des noeuds non non non j'ai été
béret vert effectivement chez badge est
ce que j'ai fait un service long voilà
bon donc mais je prendrai mes gars donc
j'avais cette sensibilité et c'est une
chose que j'ai beaucoup poussé au medef
c'est les gens prennent conscience qu'en
fait bon c'est une situation assez
connus mais les pays n'ont pas
d'internât pas d'amis ils n'ont que des
intérêts mais
vous bien que vous compreniez que c'est
c'est par un réflexe naturel quand on
fait du commerce enfin quand on fait du
business
donc cette espèce de réflexe
sain de se dire bon sont les intérêts
des uns des autres comment on navigue
dans cette géopolitique compliquée elle
est pas l est pas complètement naturel
ses premiers points le deuxième point
c'est que oui il ya des liens avec
les services de renseignements mais il
se traite beaucoup au niveau 2 des
entreprises
directement donc le medef a pas comment
dire à intervenir ce qu'on essaye de
faire nous c'est de d'évangéliser de
propager dans les pme les petites boîtes
quand pas du tout ce type de réflexe
notamment les boîtes qui ont des
technologies hybride
technologies j'ai bien expliqué mais en
gros de plus en plus les technologies
militaires sont des techniques qui
viennent du civil ou quelque part sont
utilisés ville il ya beaucoup de boîtes
qui font alors que bmc des drones les
drones ça a commencé et drones de
proximité ça a commencé d'un français
est d'ailleurs cas
inventé le drone de proximité parrot
henri seydoux et puis après c'est
utilisé par des militaires le cas on se
définissent pas égoïste et par des
théories bien sûr les droits mais
c'était en syrie vous devez savoir des
chats avaient bricolé des drôles ils
avaient blindés la partie inférieure des
drones ebay les à les balancer des
explosifs ou des
grenades sur les forces kurdes où les
forces en face donc tout ça pour dire
qu'on essaye nous de d'évangéliser cette
idée avec toujours une difficulté
permanente c'est que une entreprise qui
se referme qui protège tous qui devient
parano elle perd sa capacité ou en tout
elle réduit sa capacité à commercer
aller de l'avant et c'est donc on est
toujours dans une schizophrénie un peu
un peu par ma note puis après il ya une
troisième volet qui est celui de la
conquête des marchés étrangers
où on essaye alors il ya comme une
espèce de filiales de medef qui
s'appelle bnf internationale avec un
conseil par pays et on essaie d'aller à
la conquête des pays étrangers avec des
groupes de chaînes mais c'est un truc
qu'on n'est pas bons en france
historiquement pour chasser en meute les
allemands les italiens sont beaucoup
mieux organisés
bon moi j'ai beaucoup pousser ça j'ai
fait un simple de voyage de deux de
prospection j'étais en ukraine au mois
de juillet bon avant que ça devienne un
peu plus compliqué encore que c'était
déjà un peu un peu de sous jacents et
est lancé l'idée que les grandes boîtes
et de les petites que par secteur on
essaie de créer une offre complète on
essaie de faire ça aussi sur la filière
nucléaire par exemple voilà il ya tout
cet aspect un peu chasser en meute sur
lequel historiquement n'a jamais été
très bon c'est magnifique qui s est fait
une très belle ville je vous le confirme
c'était quoi la question la question
c'est enfin la question de d'avant papa
pas celle là c'était qu'est ce que vous
faites pour
protéger les entreprises cellule de
prospective cellule de prospective ouais
alors non pas une cellule de prospective
on essaye à travers nos commissions à la
commission par par thème d'essayer de
réfléchir un peu plus que l'actualité
qui nous occupe beaucoup donc on a une
commission innovation une des choses que
j'ai inauguré au medef ça va me ramener
au sujet précédent c'est comme j'ai créé
une commission de souveraineté
souveraineté économique souvent
s'appelle si on prend le terme complet
commission souveraineté économique et
sécurité des entreprises ça l'air de
rien mais le mot souveraineté c'était
tabou avant c'était ouais ouais on peut
dire ce qu'ils disaient en faisant 2
s'ouvre une pub le plus de sous une
pluie ils étaient tout de suite qui est
normé cellule connoté politiquement
tient souverainisme etc et c'était assez
tabou dans le monde de l'entreprise donc
ça monde avait en fait je les fais il ya
trois ans donc quand je suis arrivé donc
bien avant les pour que ça devienne à
travers locaux vides un sujet un peu
plus grand public on a invité j'ai vu
que vous l'aviez d'ailleurs invité sur
votre chaîne ya quelques mois ou années
je sais pas frédéric pietrucci de alstom
hyper hot chip arnaud qui s'est fait
elle même qui est passé bach a passé
deux ans en taule n'importe où
d'ailleurs aux états unis pas n'importe
où gp où certains redoutent sécurité oui
oui un décor pas n'importe où sans ce
type de prison quoi
voilà donc on a
contribué modestement à essayer de faire
prendre conscience aux patrons français
qu' on n'était pas dans un monde de
béni-oui-oui que
on peut avoir des alliés qui pour autant
avec des intérêts différents et
et que dans l'autre sens on pourra voir
des maisons des pays qui paraissent plus
hostile avec lequel il fallait quand
même faire du commerce et les deux
sombres et il faut être capable de faire
à la fois du commerce sans être naïf sur
les intentions des uns et des autres il
ya une forme de guerre économique mais
qui est au fond assez différente de ce
qu'on ait enfin le mot guerre économique
est finalement pas très bon parce que
c'est une compétition économie ce qui
est inventé le terme d'ailleurs
ces vieux enfin j'ai reçu de ça
plusieurs dizaines d'années mais on est
dans une compétition économique ou
presque tous les moyens sont bons
fonctions un peu d'aidé je vous donne un
exemple très concret là qui nous est
arrivé il est arrivé à l'académie
française il ya
quelques mois maintenant les chinois ont
mis en place une nouvelle norme
d'importation des produits cosmétiques
en fait en gros quand vous importants
produits cosmétiques en chine et aux
états unis sait pas et on vous demande
la liste des ingrédients bon jusque là
rien de fait assez classique sauf que là
ils ont demandé en plus en gros la
méthode pour le fabriquer tél comme dans
une recette de cuisine vous avez les
ingrédients mais pouvait pas faire le
plein mais si vous avez les ingrédients
et la recette très précises vous pouvez
faire le produit et se faire ouvrir avec
une réglementation ses seins exactement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la guerre des
normes
effectivement ça permettrait au
conditionnel aux chinois de faire des
produits équivalents à au produit de
l'oréal de lancôme etc et c'est très
compliqué pour ces masses et marc là
parce que c'est à la fois un énorme
marché
quelquefois pour certaines le plus grand
marché au monde donc elles veulent pas
perdre
ce business là et en même temps elles se
font comme vous dites ouvrir
légalement en tout cas du point de vue
chinois donc c'est un dilemme c'est
deviennent prisonniers ainsi jeudi
si je donne pas ma formule en gros je
peux plus vendre mais si je donne ma
formule un moment ou un autre je serai
copier alors dans les cosmétiques mais
pas touchés
on peut le dire comme ça et non mais en
gros dans le monde des cosmétiques
il ya aussi une notion de marketing de
marque etc qui est moins facile à copier
mais ce qui est intéressant en tout cas
qui doit nous alerter c'est que dans
cette compétition on pouvait penser que
la chine s'était entre guillemets juste
bons à copier on n'en est plus là du
tout du tout du tout du tout alors je
vous coupe
on ne l'a pas vu venir donc on s'est
fait surprendre parce qu'on n'avait pas
anticipé ouais on l'a pas vu venir oui
enfin moment tout cas pas assez bien sûr
pas ses heures passées de l'histoire
parce que c'était alors sur la chine en
particulier alors pourquoi je pense que
il ya une forme de naïveté c'est à dire
que il faut se souvenir 1,92 seller
baisse ici naïveté il faut arrêter le
délire 6ème et lire moi je sais enfin
pour appeler ça comme vous voulez jeu
plus agressif pourquoi on n'avance pas
mais je vous refais une histoire dans
l'instant cent jours fait l'histoire
dans le sens 92 la chine est un pays du
tiers-monde au sens ce niveau de vie
niveau qualité de ses ingénieurs
variable il n'y a pas d'économie ehpad
industries chinoises et clinton dit on
va faire entrer la chine dans l' omc et
mais il sait pas tellement ça qui est
intéressant c'est pourquoi calé
raisonnement qu'il ya derrière
l'allemand qui est un raisonnement assez
anciens qui vient de plein de penseurs
économiques c'est beaucoup y amar non
non non c'est pas fou climat c'est bien
avant bien bien plus anciens c'est
friedman c'est d'autres c'est de dire ce
qui a été vrai historiquement liberté
économique et libertés politiques vont
toujours de pair et c'est vrai à
l'histoire la révolution de 1789 pas les
ouvriers qu'il en fait c'est des
bourgeois
donc l'idée c'était que si la chine est
entrée dans l'âme c'est si petit à petit
ils rentraient dans l'économie de marché
d'une manière ou d'une autre il allait
aller vers la démocratie occidentale et
pendant un moment ça a été vrai est-ce
que deng xiaoping a ouvert il ya une
forme de libération ils ont laissé en
compte tranquille enfin il ya bien on
sait bien faire on dort bien non je
dirais pas ça comme ça parce que moi je
n'ai qu'à conclure après j'essaie plus
subtile non mais j'ai bien compris mais
c'est plus subtil que ça parce que ce
raisonnement il peut valoir dans un
monde occidental
il peut valoir quand en fait autour de
certaines valeurs que la situation
occidental qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas a quand même quelque part dans son
adn
l'oxydation judéo-chrétienne et donc la
démocratie elle est en fait très
consubstantiel de cette civilisation
lésions asiatiques et notamment les
chinois c'est autre chose c'est
confucius et une autre un autre adn une
autre histoire et puis aussi quand même
la revanche que les chinois han 30 sur
les deux mille dernières années on croit
les 2000 c'est c'est quand on les a
transformés en junkie pourrais je pense
que ça m'a même pas bon yaya le 19e
siècle a donc on peut dire les 200
dernières années si vous voulez mais
enfin je pense que ça bien de 2,2 de
plus un bon bref pour faire simple ça
n'a pas marché et après il ya le
phénomène jean ping
qui quand même qui a pris un peu tout le
monde par surprise parce que c'est vrai
que ce cette manière d'affirmer
une sorte de nationalisme conquérant a
pris tout le monde par surprise en jeu
pas si c'est de la naïveté en tout cas
l'association lequel on est aujourd'hui
c'est que on veut continuer à faire du
commerce avec la chine on veut continuer
à faire des affaires mais il faut le
faire en étant conscient qu' on est avec
un rival systémique qui est à la fois un
fournisseur à la fois un concurrent est
à la fois parfois un partenaire on
reviendra sur les cellules de
prospective et ainsi de suite
la question c'est ok les chinois copier
ou éthique au pied ils ont amélioré la
technique maintenant on est en short
voir avec le short sur les chevilles
est-ce qu'il faut cliquer les chinois
non je crois pas en un esquif c'est je
vais répondre d'une autre manière parce
que là il ya les côtés un peu produits
machin nous on a une histoire on a un
millier d'années d'histoire on a
construit un modèle de capitalisme
décoller mais marché qui est différent
des états unis et qui différent de la
chine mais le résultat c'est le même nom
on est passé par la consommation non
mais ne riez pardon c'est le modèle
chinois c'est l'hyper consommation
modèle européen c'est pas qu'on peut
appeler ça l'hyperconsommation simulés
mais il ya peut-être que vu de très loin
en impression que c'est les mêmes
modèles mais c'est pas du tout les mêmes
modèles vous voit pas ça de très loin
non mais d'accord mais je veux dire le
même temps tous les jours oui mais vous
avez en europe quand vous n'êtes pas en
chine ni aux états unis etats unis c'est
un modèle de capitalisme ultra libéral
sans protection sociale où seule la
réussite de l'individu compte ya pas de
mutualisation et c'est en europe peuple
et sales capitalistes mais en réalité
c'est alors le terme historique c'est
économie sociale de marché c'est quand
même un système où quand vous tombez au
chômage vous avez une protection quand
vous êtes malade
la sécu est là pour prendre le relais
aux états unis vous savez très bien
qu'il ya des tas de gens qu'ils
renoncent à se faire opérer ou à soigner
parce que ça coûte trop cher et en chine
vous avez encore un autre système où il
ya zéro liberté politique enfin très
faible liberté politique où
contrairement à ce qu'on croit les
inégalités ont crû de manière
invraisemblable
depuis dix ans de 20 ans les pays
contrairement à ce qu'on croit les pays
elle était acceptée vous savez pourquoi
cette taxe à ce que tout le monde s'est
enrichi ce qui compte c'est pas le
niveau ni égalité c'est que le niveau de
vie global de tout le monde à monter
donc les gens à accepter les chinois
entre guillemets moyens à accepter parce
qu'il vivait mieux est d'ailleurs un des
sujets de la chine c'est le taux de
croissance c'est à dire que un peu comme
quelqu'un qui fait du vélo
vu la population vu la démographie si il
n'ya pas 6% de croissance
tous les tous les ans baiia 1 de
problèmes et un risque politique fort
mais je finis juste mais enfin ma
démonstration mon argumentation sur le
capitalisme européen je pense qu'il faut
pas copier la chine il faut pas copier
les états unis et parfois on se trompe
on doit essayer d'inventer avec notre
histoire
avec nous des mots nos faiblesses avec
la complexité énorme d'avoir 27 pays un
modèle différent par signifie que ces
magnifiques j'ai l'impression d'en
finir quand même jugé une chance de
finir un système différent qui est moins
inégalitaire
qui protège mieux qu'il met un peu de
musique si vous voulez mais nan parce
que c'est la réalité c'est moins
d'inégalités en europe que saleh aux
états unis que saleh en chine tout le
problème c est ce que ça fait de la
croissance est-ce que ça crée de la
richesse est-ce que c'est compétitif
face à deux autres systèmes c'est une
guerre de systèmes au fond c'est une
guerre de dire économique pardon donc
une bonne guerre économique mais oui si
vous voulez me faire dire que
c'est par wendy dans le home gateway
mais le mot guerre donne tout de suite
une connotation j'allais dire du sang et
des larmes c'est une compétition féroce
comme le support connaissez vous
connaissez ce qu'on dit en guerre
économique un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort pour affaiblir son adversaire
ouais donc pas commenter une phrase
aussi j'ai à dire cynique non je sais si
éric la galerie comme il faut non il
faut pas tomber du mauvais côté du
manche c'est à dire oui à une
compétition féroce
ont parfois tous les coups sont permis
où nous adversaires concurrents et
parfois alliés utilisent des méthodes
keith ont réprouvé et pas et pas légal
pour autant pour autant en français ça
se dire et comment réprouvé pas légal et
illégal ce qui est comme vous voulez
faire venir des méthodes mais que non
mes méthodes de de bâtard
si vous voulez oui mais n'imaginez pas
non plus que toute l'économie américaine
est tourné vers l'espionnage des heurts
peu européenne tous les autres ouais
elle mais énorme et nous le qu'un petit
marché mais je vois bien comment dire le
raisonnement qu'il ya derrière
raisonnement le raisonnement c'est de
dire que le lait les autres continents
passent leur temps et enfin les autres
pays passent leur temps à espionner à
ouvrir comme vous dites etc oui ça
existe mais c'est pas l'essentiel de la
croissance américaine panne on ne vient
pas de là vient de la dette non elle
vient d'un capacim capacité
entrepreneuriale extraordinaire de la
capacité qu'ils ont à faire travailler
ensemble leur université d'un côté leurs
chercheurs
leurs entrepreneurs ont aspiré nos
talents avec des permis spéciaux oui
alors il ya aussi les talents français
qui sont là bas donc il ya aimé finir
c'est que c'est c'est pas tout blanc et
noir c'est pas les méchants américains
qui font que nous copier machin c'était
un et puis les gentils crétins européen
ou français qui se font avoir chausson
vous avec lui quand c'est plus complexe
que ça voilà mais je l'aimé guère de
schiste m merci de résumer merci de
résume ce que vous décrivez avec votre
interprétation mon raisonnement comme
blanc et noirs mais moi je vais vous
dire comme le chinois a dit à montebourg
ya les gagnants et les perdants d'accord
l'aga les gagnants et les perdants le
résultat est le suivant la france est en
danger le business français est en
danger il ça fait trois-quatre ans
qu'est patron ce travail nous m'ont dit
c'est bien beau les comptes les contes
de fées oui pénible ancenis noir mais on
a une expression en france et quand on
use achi dans les votes il faut savoir
un peu sans rappeler
les patrons français ils vont faire quoi
pour se rappeler que c'est ni blanc ceni
noir le résultat c'est en ce moment on
est en danger
nous a choisis sont en danger notre
économie est en danger donc est-ce qu'il
serait peut-être pas moment de changer
de braquet
c'est à dire que le linge est bon parce
que celle inverse cela maintenant c'est
moi qui vous pose des questions vous
écoutant en venant vous inquiétez pas
pour ça qu'on vous écoute ans j'ai
vraiment l'impression que c'est aussi
pertinent qu'un phillies d'hôtes y est
brodé par un conseiller en com non mais
c'est parce que nous aimons vous avez
vous avez déjà dirigé des entreprises
vis du patron ici on est tous ces
patrons au hockey vous utilisez les
entreprises et j'ai conquis dès
maintenant avec tous les airs mais tend
à présent je vais finir ma phrase bon
quand vous êtes patron et voulait vendre
à l'étranger
vos clients chinois vos clients
américains c'est à la fois des
concurrents dont il faut se méfier mais
c'est aussi les clients et c'est ça qui
rend le sujet beaucoup plus complexe que
changer de braquet ça veut dire quoi
changer de braquet s'est plus vendu aux
états unis sectionner les américains
cette peur on le fait déjà avec babar
mais on aime bien sûr qu'on le fait est
alors et donc non échange est parti
c'est à dire devenir méchant et
combattants mais les fringues les
patrons français ils sont combattants
allaient arrêter de me dire qu'il ya que
des idiots du village naïfs qui se font
espionner avec plaisir de l'entente
quand même non non donc que cdi du
village dont on fait un bep des
combattants oui mais bien sûr que c'est
des combattants ils sont tous dire mais
oui mais bien sûr mais c'est une
compétition donc c'est des compétiteurs
si vous préférez bon donc que oui et les
compétiteurs il ya des canassons il ya
des chevaux de course ben oui comme dans
sûr je pas combien on est
deux heures trente ou quarante mille
entreprises qui exportent un pivot qui
vont à la conquête des marchés en france
à la suite des bons des mauvais et puis
à ce qu'ils n'exportent pas qu'ils sont
peut-être pas assez combatif pas assez
conquérant il y aurait plein de choses à
dire sur le manque d'entreprises
exportatrices en france comparé à
l'allemagne et à l'italie donc bon mais
je sais pas votre question donc est-ce
qu'il faut changer de braquet en tout
cas est-ce qu'il faut réveiller et
éveiller les consciences des autres des
patrons force et c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire sur ces sujets de géostratégie
mais moi je veux pas de tomber c'est pas
du filet d'eau tiède c'est ma conviction
donc prêt vous en faites ce que vous
voulez du mauvais côté du manche qui est
de dire finalement ces espèces de guerre
économique donc c'est les uns contre les
autres non parce que je peux trouver des
partenaires aux états unis qui vont être
de bonne foi qui je peux avoir un
contrat avec qui je vais faire des
affaires et qui vont faire grandir mon
entreprise on b les choses sont plus
compliquées que ça ça vous dit l'esprit
et les marchés publics juste pour finir
sur lequel là il ya un sujet de
réciprocité et puis il ya un sujet que
vous connaissez sûrement bien et qui
nous pose problème manière c'est la
domination des gars femme parce que là
c'est vrai que là toute la croissance de
l'économie vient du numérique et qu'on
est entre les mains de quelques monopole
mondiaux que les états unis protègent et
qui pose un problème de concurrence le
droit de la concurrence au fond et qui
était un problème de fiscalité par
ailleurs mais d'abord un problème de
droit de la concurrence parce que
quelque part quand google fais plus
70% n'ont pas tous à 90 % des requêtes
en france c'est un quasi monopole
il ya eu des essais de deux modèles
français et européens ou alternatifs qui
auraient été des échecs patenté je vais
pas citer l'entreprise donc là on a un
sujet et ça ça se réglera que avec des
décisions étatique et gouvernementale
contient un monopole le droit de la
concurrence doit intervenir moi je suis
affirme libéral mais la vraie la vraie
économie libérale c'est quand on ne
laisse pas un monopole s'installer or là
il ya des monopoles il ya un monopole
pas tout à fait un monopole sur la vente
par internet amazon ya un monopole sur
les réseaux sociaux avec un seul doigt
sociaux que vous connaissez et c'est là
on est diffusée sur youtube qui est
sciences pures tube surprise mais a
fallu je pense que la part à la part des
vues vous faites sur youtube est bien
plus élevé bien sûr on passe presque il
ya un monopole de facto d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses chacun d'entre nous
chaque individu qui regardent peut en
cliquant n'achetant pas c'est amazon
mais en achetant chez un site français
etc etc peu réseaux sociaux c'est plus
compliqué parce que bon c'est un affront
que twitter c'est twitter mais il ya
aussi cédé un point important il ya
aussi une sorte de patriotisme de la
consommation qui est difficile à mettre
en oeuvre passe car maman quand vous
avez une différence de prix de qualité
de service a demandé aux gens d'acheter
français si c'est moins bon en gros mais
n'empêche que ça fait partie du truc et
c'est vrai ce que je sens que vous êtes
en fin de tournée autour de cette idée
que vous sentez le coach ce soir pardon
peut-être que le patriotisme économique
et pas un mot complètement naturel c'est
villepin donc avait parlé patriotisme
économique y a pas dit que des conneries
junon il ya bien que tu as dit laconique
mais quand même bien oui mais alors
c'est c'est là où le pour faire un peu
de presque de psychologie de base
quelquefois le cerveau du patron il est
pris entre saint presque une
schizophrénie entre son intérêt de deux
commerçants et son et j'allais dire son
son son coeur ou son cerveau de citoyens
et son cerveau de citoyens patriotes
et quand vous regardez d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant tout tout la french tech
le problème de la french tech qui bon
vous avez dû suivre ce qui s'est passé
les licornes les trucs et des machins là
donc il ya quand même une vraie
différence nord il ya une vraie
différence moi quand j'ai monté ma
première boîte à prendre trop d'impôts
trop du pognon trouvait pas bon parce
que la tex est intéressé personne qu'il
ya quand même une vraie différence et le
problème c'est que toutes ces boîtes ont
des vocations quelque part à se vendre
et se vendre probablement à
l'étranger et donc en termes de création
d' autonomie stratégique création de
valeur en europe et en france ben
on n'y est pas encore et
c'est quoi ce qg les highfive dorian
attendait parce que on va prendre les
histoires de klout souverain le machin
pourquoi on n'y arrive pas parce qu'il
ya des acteurs d'autres pays sur notre
territoire qui nous disons c'est pas
très bien ou si vous faites ça vous
pourrez pas vous projetez chez nous bon
parce qu'on a des dirigeants politiques
à l'ouest
je pense que la raison numéro un n'est
pas ce que vous dites est vrai il ya par
des pressions de grands acteurs
internationaux
multinationaux il ya une mauvaise
compréhension de l'importance
stratégique de la tech encore que ça
progresse mais
c'est pas si vous laissez pas comment
dire la puissance d'un pays se mesure
plus aujourd'hui à la puissance de cet
acte ortec qu'à d'autres secteurs de
l'économie mais c'est pas encore ça pas
encore percolé assez dans le dans le
cerveau des dirigeants politiques qui
sont pas complètement câble et là dessus
mais le vrai point de départ c'est
concret pas assez de deux d'entreprise
dans ces secteurs là à potentiel parce
qu'on n'a pas la même le même système
quand vous allez en silicon valley oui
vous avez des ingénieurs français mais
ils viennent parce que c'est l'endroit
au monde où il ya tout il ya tout moi je
veux dire j'ai un fils qui a fait des
fins qui a fait des émules en france
après les parties abertis mois et il est
revenu bon il est revenu parce que parce
qu'il est français parce qu'il aime bien
vivante parce qu'il aime bien bouffer
français et voilà six emplois en france
et epub à wimille est revenue sinus
équipe et c'est un pauvre mais c'est pas
ça c'est que effectivement d'un point de
vue travaille dans un domaine assez
pointu médical relire biotech mais ces
conditions de travail les outils qu'ils
savent être l'expression le réseau qu'il
avait manqué en silicon valley ou à
boston fin c'est un peu le choix en
biotech et est dix fois plus important
ce qu'ils avaient en europe et donc
c'est ça aussi qui fait la force et
c'est pas simplement des menaces des
voiliers des méthodes douteuses et c'est
tard je dis pas que ça existe pas mais
faut pas sous-estimer la capacité du
système américain
ça crée de la richesse des entreprises
et c'est fort quand c'est dû interpréter
ce qui s'est passé que les sous-marins
français
d'abord alors sur cette affaire que j'ai
suivi un peu première chose c'est qu'en
fait du point de vue strictement
économique
c'est pas une catastrophe pour la
construction navale et pour des c faut
pas se tromper au fond il ya énormément
de choses qui étaient faites en
australie est donc bon c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle mais je ne sais pas pas
la faillite d'ailleurs navale groupe a
pas spécialement annoncé qu'ils allaient
être dans des prénoms dits fêté par
contre du point de vue géopolitique
c'est un rappel à l'ordre pour le
personnifie de français pour tous les
patrons français que les pays n'ont pas
d'amis ils n'ont que des intérêts et
l'australie et à maman il s'en dit si
jamais les chinois viennent
à un moment ou un autre dans nos eaux
territoriales est ce que ces américains
qui viendront ou est ce que c'est les
français mais alors moi maman de pin
personnel là je m'exprime pas tellement
donc présents mais là ce n'est plus tout
citoyen c'est que c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre ils se trompent voilà ils ont
cru mais peut-être à tort enfin en tout
cas l'avenir le dira que face à la
menace qu'ils perçoivent très fort de la
chine leur meilleur protecteur c'était
des américains et donc du pot bas maman
il n'y a pas de vous avez la même chose
quand j'ai à dire c'est facile à
comprendre quand les polonais achètent
des hélicoptères américains alors qu'ils
sont en europe dans le marché plutôt que
des hélicoptères
français puis on essaie de le revendre
je puisse et les caracal on essayait de
leur vente pendant très longtemps un
hélicoptère c'est parce qu'ils se disent
si un jour les russes à vous acquise
dans la pologne la russie on peut en
parler pendant plusieurs centaines
d'années c'est forcément très très très
compliqué pour plein de raisons c'est
les américains qui le protège en est l
inverse c'est intéressant quand les
grecs achètent des rafale l'a
dernièrement cet aveu ou des tanks ou
dénommé the les bateaux si c'était chez
les allemands qu'ils ont acheté quand il
sait c'est qu'ils se disent les turcs
sont dans le temps son allié des
américains nous on a besoin de quelqu'un
qui soit pas lié aux turcs et comme en
plus il ya eu toutes ces frictions que
vous avez suivi en méditerranée entre
erdogan entre les bateaux turcs et les
bateaux français etc voilà les ennemis
de mes ennemis sont mes amis enfin c'est
la géopolitique au fond d'une certaine
manière on revient à des choses assez
simples alors quand c'est sur des sujets
aussi régalien aussi important que
l'armement et c'est évidemment c'est
facile à lire
quand on est dans des business plus
c'est à dire plus mass market plus - -
voyez moins spectaculaire bas c'est plus
subtil et c'est souvent amis ennemis
mélanger et est ce que les américains il
je pose la question c'est la supposition
est ce que les américains sont pas
pointer auprès des australiens en disant
écoutez les sous-marins français c'est
des grosses bouses
nous on a un système d'armement avec des
torpilles quand on tire sa touche
dans la seconde eux ils ont des
torpilles filoguidé ils prennent leur
petit chronomètre il tire et puis
on joue est le petit fils est-ce qu'ils
ont pas dit vous savez en face les
chinois ils ont le même type de
torpilles vaut mieux que vous vous
battiez avec les mêmes armes parce que
les sous-marins français c'est
l'équivalent de l' arc et des flèches et
nous on a une mini gun non mes choix
d'abord ce que vous dites n'est pas
parce que vous dites l'argumentation est
fausse pourquoi parce que la proposition
de de naval groupe était en terme de
défense je parle pas de prix très
compétitive comme vous le savez ils ont
pris les sous marins à propulsion
nucléaire chez les américains après vous
nous avoir commandé enfin après avoir
fait un appel d'offres sur des sous
marins classiques c'est parce que les
écolos australien et fait pression c'est
ça je connais pas assez d'histoire on
pourrait admettre mais la fin des fins
c'est quoi c'est qu'ils ont fait un
choix
géostratégique de salies et américains
avec une grosse faiblesse mais qui qui
donc ils sont conscients c'est que comme
tout armement américain un moment ou un
autre si les tenues d'ici on peut pas
les utiliser on pourra pas les utiliser
par construction coup parce qu'on avait
on n'a pas la technologie non c'est pas
ça c'est que les américains ont
forcément dans tous les allemands qui
vendent yves logghe petit plug le truc
qui va bien pour m en fait ils ont
choisi ils ont fait comme les anglais
c'est les anglais et laisse vous savez
les anglais on dit de ce contrat là
c'est le contrat des sous marins
nucléaires le contrat contient une puce
américaine dont n'importe quoi et qui
disent s'il ya je sais pas mais juste
pour revenir deux minutes les anglais
c'est pareil les anglais n'ont pas de
dissuasion nucléaire propre
les laisser là où je patiente parlera de
gaulle mais c'est là où de gaulle a eu
une vision
extraordinaire et qui nous portent
encore c'est que le seul pays
aujourd'hui
à part évidemment la chine les
etats-unis et la russie qui construit
ces sous marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins entièrement en france avec de
la technique de france
alstom santé ou la une ce qui met
d'abord avec alstom sous marin nucléaire
je vous parle des sous marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins d'accord mais je finis
juste les sous marins nucléaires un
changeur faut voir ce que c'est un jeu
pas si vous avez déjà visité en cellule
anin entre une ariane est incompétent
mais c'est le plus gros concentré
technologie affaire on est les seuls
avec les ruches les américains et les
chinois à le faire nous mêmes une façade
alstom là dedans ça n'a pas nui à notre
souveraineté à côté j'ai pas le
spécialiste mondial du sous marin
nucléaire j'avais pas passer pour ce que
je ne suis pas mais je ne crois pas
alstom si vous faites allusion aux
turbines je crois c'est ça turbines
alstom aujourd'hui plus personne n'en
veut donc est-ce que c'était le bon le
mauvais choix j'en sais rien en tout cas
plus personne ne me est en tout cas ça
n'a pas si pour répondre à votre
question je ne crois pas que ses impacts
et notre autonomie stratégique sur la
dissuasion nucléaire parce que les
patrons français est ce que le medef a
son mot à dire sur les questions
géopolitiques
ont contré nous comme d'autres non mais
c'est à son mot à dire ces macro
n'appelle pas pour me dire ce que je
vois qu'est ce qu'il doit faire sur le
calcul ça vous a plu est ce que vous
vous appelez macron pour vous dire
maintenant pépère tu vas être calmer
parce qu'on est bien
mais moi je ne suis pas je suis ni élu
ni ministre belge pas légitimité
politique pour faire ça simplement je
porte la voix des entreprises enfin des
patrons gdba pour les entreprises
françaises ce qui se passe en ce moment
entre la russie et
l'europe et pas une bonne nouvelle nous
on veut la désescalade bon moi à titre
personnel je crois pas trop que
ce qu'on nous raconte sur un
envahissement possible faut voir un peu
la carte et boussole et où sont les
comment dire les militaires russes
laissant militaires russes pensent que
tout ça est pas très crédible par contre
il ya un concours d'ici l'été place pour
un trouble gigantesque d2 oui mais je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse envahir
l'ensemble du territoire quand on
regarde où sont les troupes la taille de
l'ukraine je crois pas qu'on puisse
envahir l'ukraine jusqu'à kiev avec cent
mille soldats ont tenté que juste pour
le dombass c'est tout oui d'accord mais
c'est pas ça qu'on nous raconte puisque
on évacue pardon mais je enfin on sort
un peu du sujet mais on évacue et le
personnel militaire américain de kiev
donc on est train d'expliquer que bon
tout ça n'est pas bon pour les affaires
moi je pense que la russie fait partie
de l'europe au sens gaullien du terme
c'est-à-dire de l'atlantique à l'oural
et qu' on doit trouver la manière de
trouver un équilibre
la russie un système politique qui n'est
pas celui qu'on approuve ça n'est pas
une démocratie ni à un centre de choses
qui sont pas comment dire
contre les droits de l'homme pour autant
on ne va pas entrer en guerre avec eux
son film en est s'il franchit ce rubicon
qui n'ont qui n'ont pas franchi on passe
du coq à l'âne question internet où sont
passés les 40 milliards du cic et le
million d'emplois promis là il a été
créé bien plus bien plus à combien les
emplois d'emploi 10 balles
ça sert à quoi des emplois payés pas
cher quoi déjà il ya un smic en france
donc les emplois des balles ça n'existe
pas on peut trouver ce mal c'est seydou
seuls 12 12 82 12 20 le leur fut fatal
quand c'est brut ou net enfin ce à
l'heure devant verser 12 euros de
l'heure alors le cic eux
sa mère est une toute petite explication
la frontière d'eau avant non non ça va
se voir ajouter je dirais la france est
le pays le deuxième pays dans le cd qui
taxe le plus globalement c'est d'abord
ses citoyens et ses entreprises les deux
les deux vont ensemble entre guillemets
il ya énormément de charges sociales
quand vous employez quelqu'un vous payez
alors ça dépend du salaire à ce que vous
pouvez dire est ce que vous pouvez dire
cotisations sociales si vous les
cotisations sociales en mai bien sûr
cotisations sociales donc vous payer des
cotisations sociales élevées qui
financent bas ce que j'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure la maladie retraite alors la
retraite c'est un peu compliqué parce
que comme vous le savez on est sur un
système où c'est des actifs qui payent
pour les retraités donc bon et donc le
séisme c'était quoi c'est une baisse de
cotisations sociales
pour favoriser l'emploi alors
le million qu'elle fait allusion votre
votre internaute c'était à l'époque moi
j'étais pas c'est pas mal président du
medef l'idée de dire si vous baissez les
cotisations sociales vous aurez la
création d'emplois d'air et mais la
réalité c'est que ça s'est produit alors
ça s'est pas produit instantanément
parce que quand un patron lui baisse ses
charges ou ses cotisations ou une baisse
des impôts il va attendre quelques mois
voire quelques années pour à 6 et
pérenne parce qu'en france on a
l'habitude de changer les lois très
régulièrement mais la réelle et en
fonction gbagbo alors politique une
politique est lui-même quelques fois
même le même politique peut changer
plusieurs fois de manière de taxation
bref le patron enfin les patrons
français ils ont attendu et au final il
ya plus d'un million d'emplois qui ont
été créés depuis 2014 dans le privé je
lui sers pour que soient comparables il
n'y a pas que pour dire la vérité il
n'ya pas que le cicr qui a contribué
bien sûr mais il ya plein d'autres
facteurs parce que un patron qui décide
d'embaucher ça dépend de son carnet de
commandes ça dépend de sa confiance ça
dépend de la personne qu'il a en face de
lui donc c'est multifactoriel s'est
jamais binaire mais il est clair qu'il
ya un lien quand même entre la taxation
sur les entreprises au sens très large
les cotisations les impôts que paient
les entreprises et l'emploi et la bonne
nouvelle
c'est que on est prêt après le coville
un taux d'emploi je parle pas du taux de
chômage taux d'emploi c'est le nombre de
gens employés sur la population en âge
de travailler qu'on va grosso modo qui
est le plus haut depuis alors shit mais
jean 15 ans et ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle que la maman la richesse d'un
pays c'est le nombre de gens qui
travaillent at-il dit d'accord si c'est
la richesse c'est la richesse d'un pays
c'est le nombre de gens qui travaillent
les roumains ils sont très riches non il
traque mais vous avez tort vous avez
tort le taux d'emploi roumanie est très
faible en hongrie aussi mais tous ces
pays là ont des taux d'emploi faible
mais bien sûr qu'après si on paye tout
le monde à 400 euros de règles n'a pas
la même richesse créée je suis bien
d'accord mais en france on a on avait
historiquement un problème de taux
d'emploi terre de nombre de gens
employés non je sais en train de casser
en train de s'améliorer tout ça ça fait
quoi c'est plus à des gens qui
travaillent plus là des gens qui
consomment paix de la tva puis à des
gens qui payent des cotisations sociales
puis les gens qui payent des impôts tout
ça ça permet de financer balle tout le
système qu'on a encore comment ils font
pour consommer quand il ya de
l'inflation et que les salaires alors
d'abord l'appelation elle démarre mais
peut-être juste pour laisser le truc de
côté deux minutes plus vous appuyez sur
quelqu'un qui est chômeur qui parce
qu'ils insèrent d'emploi forcément il va
plus consommer que quand il était
chômeur il n'y a pas de mystère
maintenant sur l'inflation via le
redémarrage de l'inflation
2,8 disent les chiffres monde 1 500 noms
alors on va faire un petit débat à
l'inter du débat est ce que le taux
d'inflation officiel reflète la
véritable inflation moi je crois que non
je crois qu'au mans pour plusieurs
raisons qui sont qui sont de nature
différente d'abord en fait le panier de
consommation fallait ce que consomme
quelqu'un avec un salaire moyen est pas
la même chose que quelqu'un qui est tout
en haut de l'échelle des salaires ou
quelqu'un qui est tout en bas nos
courses ça dépend en général dans mon
quartier
mais je fais de temps en temps des
achats internet et j'essaye d'éviter
l'entreprise dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure du coup j'ai pas eu ce
que je voulais dire ou abaissé celle où
il ya des des problèmes avec les sarries
où il ya eu un entrepôt effectivement où
il ya eu des problèmes que les salariés
mais attendez du coup je voulais dire
oui donc l'inflation là les négociations
sur la lys a lieu en même en ce moment
là on engage dans les emprises il ya ce
qu'on appelle la haine à eau mais ceux
des deux sessions annuelles obligatoires
et donc les augmentations de salaires
via quelques exceptions elles ont lieu
là enfin elles vont être décidées à la
fois dans les branches et dans les dans
les entreprises dans les semaines qui
viennent je pense moi je suis j'ai pas
un bouton pour appuyer pour dire ses 3 %
c'est 2% et 4% mais je pense qu'on aura
des augmentations de salaires
supérieures à l'inflation est plus
élevée qu'on n'a pas eu depuis très
longtemps alors vous allez me dire oui
mais parce que l'inflation est plus
forte ce qui est vrai donc voilà après
ce que ça suffit pour consommer assez
bien c'est tout dépend du désir de
consommation des gens qui après c'est
une question presque presque individuel
vous portez qu'elle regarde sur les
gilet jaune
un double regard je dirais un regard
plutôt
compréhensifs au début
parce que parce que
il y avait à mon avis un double
sentiment de frustration le premier
c'est le côté
qui est un défaut de ce pays décision
centrale depuis paris par des gens qui
connaissent pas notre vie et qui vivent
pas ce qu'on vit au quotidien donc c'est
les 80 km heure etc etc le côté qui est
très français de
2,2 décision tout petit tout petit
comité et puis ce côté là aussi
ville-campagne hockey en ville pour
n'est pas votre voiture ou de moins en
moins pour circuler dans voyez pas le
prix de l'essence mais quand vous prenez
votre voiture 25 km le matin à 25 km le
soir pour bosser mois + wii ou plus
quoique ces 23 le
pendre le trajet moyen en voiture pour
aller travailler je suis quelque part en
tête et moi j'avais été assez frappé
j'ai une boîte de mon groupe là qui font
des pyrénées lavelanet ben il ya 30
personnes 30 personnes qui étaient
effectivement j'ai les jours après j'ai
un regard plus négatif quand ça a tourné
à la violence quand ça a tourné au
saccage de l'arc de triomphe quand ça
tourne et enfin tous ces trucs là quoi
parce que la violence n'est pas
excusable quel que soit voilà on est en
démocratie il faut essayer de trouver
des formes d'expression qui soit autre
chose que la violence que ce soit
derrière la violence verbale sur les
réseaux sociaux où la violence pareille
les violences sur les élus moi je viens
on peut trouver son peut reprocher tout
ce qu'on veut a perdu alors bon ça c'est
la version un peu
cynique de la faire mais je trouve que
les démocraties sont quand même assez
fragile on peut penser ce qu'on veut du
système démocratique mais moi j'y tiens
craint-il ouais ouais vous ne faut pas
pas raconter de conneries pardon mais
moi je le dis assez directement
j'entends de dire je pas quoi je peux
pas aller au restaurant si j'ai pas le
pass vaccinale houleux mais aller dans
des vrais pays non démocratiques
ou quand vous savez vous savez pas qui
vient sonner enfin quand vous obtenez la
sonnette ne sais pas si c'est on vient
vous arrêter ou pas hier donc faut pas
céder mots
les mots sont forts ils se trouvent et
montrent un sens et enlever le sang
fonds mmu rajoute de la misère sur le
monde c'est bien résumé et je trouve que
le mot dictature
le mot nazi le mot machin c'est souvent
c'est souvent mal employé c'est souvent
galvaudée pas pour pour donner enfin
pour faire le buzz quoi pour essayer de
rebondir de créer la lente lé musée
comme je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable c'est un peu ce qu'on fait depuis
le début non
alors
je m'attends au pire les emails nous ont
pas prévenus vous conseille vous comme
et je n'écoute pas toujours
la violence on parlait de violences mais
quand tous les jours à la télé il ya une
pub pour cinq fruits et légumes c'est
bon pour la santé que machin est que la
force de mettre toute votre argent tout
votre argent
pas des télé écran plat mais dans un
plein d'essence pour aller bosser pour
un salaire de misère que votre gamin
quand ils vous voient le soir etc il dit
un papa et 5 fruits et légumes c'est que
des pâtes et les pommes de terre à la
maison comment ça se fait ça c'est pas
de la violence quand
le travailleur pauvre qui a toujours
vielles avec les règles du jeu se
retrouve
avec un frigo vide
ça c'est pas de la violence bon sens
voire légitimer la violence d'abord
première remarque quand même je ne dis
pas que la vie en france la vie
quotidienne de tout le monde est
formidable mais la vraie misère aller en
afrique il se trouve qu'on a un bon fond
pour accorder ma vie mais au niger on
est déjà au niger via la fin la vraie de
la vraie souffrance celle et là je dis
pas que les organes jeudi pareil il faut
comparer
il faut comparer contre la peste le
choléra non c'est pas ça que j'ai dit m
non mais c'est pas
ce que je ferai juste pour finir ce que
je veux dire c'est que je dis pas qu'il
ya pas des gens qu'on parle frigo vide
mais la france est quand même un pays où
par les minimas sociaux pas un centre du
système de protection on arrive à aider
les gens qui qui ont des difficultés
alors qu'on attendait ça tu dion il
saute des repas parce qu'ils ont plus de
thunes parce qu'ils vivent dans des
locaux dégueulasse avec des mares
championnat mais aussi c'est la même
réponse est à dire je vous dis pas que
ça n'existe pas il faut que ces combats
durent plus en plus non pas vous êtes en
train de m'expliquer j'explique que rien
qu'on en a marre mais vous êtes en train
de me dire que c'est une violence non il
ya je vais vous répondre d'une autre
manière en c'est un choix au fond de
modèle économique
on a un modèle économique qui est
beaucoup moins de ce point de vue la
prime et violent que de mode américain
mais on pourrait faire différemment il
ya des candidats élections
présidentielles qui propose des systèmes
différents qui
jean luc mélenchon pour pas le citer par
exemple qui d'autre enfin le disons les
systèmes la gauche jean luc mélenchon
les candidats d'extrême gauche etc mais
la réponse est ce si c'est vécu comme
une violence par des gens elle est dans
les urnes et tous les ans enfin tous les
ans tous les cinq ans on a le choix pour
ça que moi je suis quand même vraiment
gêné
je suis pas spécialement soutien du
président actuel mais
ils appliquent une politique qui l'avait
annoncée avec sûrement des choses qu'il
a annoncé qu'il n'a pas fait l inverse
mais je veux dire le vrai rendez vous il
doit être le alors c'est le 10 avril 14
avril à caen c'est le fin le 1er tour de
l'exemple en fin de 1er et lille 2e tour
c'est là qu'on doit s'exprimer
donc bon voilà et on a la chance de
pouvoir s'exprimer vous savez que le
nombre de démocraties dans le monde
recule que le nombre de gens qui ont le
droit de voter et de s'exprimer recule
donc certaine manière profitons-en jeudi
profitons-en c'est-à-dire exerçons notre
nom mais papa profitez en pour vous que
ça dure enfin encore que on peut en
discuter mais exerçons notre droit les
uns et les autres de démocratie
et chacun fasse rire c'est un vrai débat
voilà sur le système économique est ce
qu'il faut plus taxés d entreprise jeu
quand on voit ce que 20 jeux pendant
trente ans que dit jean luc mélenchon je
pense que c'est pas une bonne idée je
pense que ça créera plus de pauvreté
plus de misère mais au moins c'est un
vrai débat articulé argumenté c'est la
retraite
fait quoi avec la retraite
pendant 45
nos ingénieurs nos ancêtres vous allez
nous parler de l'espérance de vie
s'allonge et laissez moi finir si vous
faites la réponse est dans la question
en 45 on a fait un choix
que beaucoup de pays européens ont fait
mais pas à cet extrême c'est là qu'on a
lié la retraite c'est les actifs qui
vont payer 100 % de la retraite des
retraités est donc en 45 y avait six
actifs pour un retraité non parce que la
démographie faisait qu'on a une
population super jeune
et donc
petit à petit on a on a réduit la
démographie a réduit le nombre de gens
qui peuvent cotiser et on arrive à un
système où on est à 1,7 je prends un
verset 8
cotisant
pour un retraité donc il ya un problème
financier bon voilà
après financier à combien de temps ah
bin là maintenant je compte le corps dit
10 milliards et puis 500 à terme après
il ya deux solutions pour être très
honnête il ya la solution qui est
d'augmenter les cotisations alors la
cotisation des salariés et la cotisation
des des entreprises que c'est que c'est
payé 60 40 en gros donc ça veut dire que
les salariés toucheront un peu moins net
pour financer les retraités d'un côté et
de l'autre les entreprises paieront plus
moi je pense que ça détruit des emplois
parce que ça veut dire que ça va coûter
plus cher à fabriquer plus cher employés
et que donc on pourra en discuter mais
ça va détruire de l'emploi et il ya
l'autre solution qui est de travailler
plus longtemps alors le débat
travaillent plus longtemps il est très
compliqué d'abord ce qu'il ya majorité
de français qui rêvent de la retraite
pas tout le monde il ya des gens qui
déprime à la retraite un poids une
majorité inquiète parce qu'ils ne
peuvent plus de travail pour oui parce
que parce que l'orteil je peux pas
répondre à leur place moi c'est pas mon
corps mais je comprends que pour des
gens ils ont envie de partir à la
retraite juste peut-être un chiffre
quand même qu'ils changent pas la
discussion mais il ya près d 1 portion
des salariés qui quand ils partent à la
retraite font une dépression parce que
parce que voilà il arrive chez eux ils
savent pas quoi faire mais c'est pas le
sujet au fond je parle de course qui
passe au près c'est ça je connais pas je
passais expert en etc et en utilisation
pour pour faire la comparaison donc le
vrai sujet il est là c'est à dire que il
faut qu'on travaille plus longtemps
alors petit 1 il faut prendre en compte
la longueur quand commence à travailler
à 18 ans commence à travailler à 25
c'est pas la même chose faut prendre en
compte la pénibilité du métier quand
vous êtes couvreur
ou quoi ou carreleur aux maçons à la
même chose que quand vous êtes de cadre
à la sncf est aide soignante
avec la matière les métiers pénibles on
peut en faire plages et juste entre
parenthèse dans cette affaire-là il ya
aussi les fonctionnaires est-ce que
fonctionnaire c'est un métier pénible ou
pas je
vous laisse répondre mais ça dépend
fonctionnaires de police oui émis par
plutôt comme vous le savez militer à pas
plutôt pompiers parlent plutôt donc on
sait plus à des fonctionnaires de
administratif bon bref
est ce que c'est juste pour finir comme
juste le donc donc à maman il ya deux
solutions il y en a trois en fait pour
être année on peut baisser les pensions
mais ça je pense que c'est impossible va
y arriver et j'espère que non non
j'espère que non j'espère que non
j'espère que non il ya une deuxième
solution qui est d'augmenter les
cotisations je pense que ce sera un
impact très négatif sur l'emploi et la
troisième qui est très pesant alors la
troisième il ya une petite variante
kékem intéressante je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure du taux d'emploi si un moment
on avait plus de gens employés ça fait
plus de cotisants pour le même nombre de
retraités et donc quand même on peut
déjà dire on peut éviter je veux dire
comme ça de travailler plus longtemps en
particulier pour ceux qui ne veulent pas
parce qu'il ya des gens comme qui ne qui
ne veulent pas travailler plus longtemps
si on arrive à faire baisser le chômage
et avoir plus de gens employés ça il
faut quand il faut pouvoir proposer du
boulou fond en bouche et oui mais on
n'embauche pas si on nous augmente les
cotisations eh bien le cercle vertueux
qui est en terme de démographie mon
trouble alors la france s'est passé
particulier en europe parce que on
continue à avoir une petite augmentation
jusqu'en 2041 je crois de la population
active donc on a la possibilité le
chiffre que je vous donnais il est bien
plus grave en allemagne pour ça que les
allemands ils travaillent jusqu'à 67 ans
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont fait venir un
million de c'est exactement pour ça
qu'ils sont fait venir enfin vous dire
que les ont fait venir mais ils ont
accepté puisque comme était un peu
surpris au moment où ça s'est passé mais
le donc sous merkel ya le souvenir trois
ans je dirais ou deux ans je paie quand
c'était le million de d'émigrés syrien
afghan et c'est qu'ils se sont installés
parce qu'ils ont un problème de déficit
de population active qui est faramineux
et eux ils travaillent jusqu'à 67 ans
aujourd'hui enfin le nouvel âge d'anti
discute plus avec ton pour être précis
le nouvelle réforme discutée 67 ans
monde y travaille en allemand arbeit on
savait bien que connaissait la
comment dire le lan le panneau qui avait
sur le camp d'auschwitz en ce jour si
exactement à rebattre maillard bart
macht frei
ont fait aucun parallèle avec le nord
avec le travail
on se on se remet un peu de géopolitique
où on passe à autre chose
moi c'est qu'ils menaient l'interview
pas moi on passe à l'écologie on peut
passer à l'écologie
est ce que vous vous rappelez de votre
université d'été vers laquelle c'était
il
ya deux ans à taille à planned
interventions dont j'ai pas tout vu et
j'ai pas tout alors allez-y je je je
pose la question internet comment
réagit-il face au passage de camille
etienne à lui l'université d'été du
parti
qu'il faut revoir l'organisation du
temps de travail et revoir tout ce
système
à bout de souffle
camille etienne qui la représentante de
la jeunesse pour le climat et elle a été
qualifiée de quoi de jeunesse ou
anxiolytiques
je ne crois pas mais bon faut ajouter
les bords pour d'abord
vous me l'accorderez si j'ose dire que
on accepte de débattre avec tout le
monde on a invité des gens qui sont
évidemment pas d'accord avec ce qu'on
propose et c'est qu'on voit en actualité
écoutez oui je pense de débattre avec
tout le monde je pense que c'est au
moins et insignes de commandeur de
d'ouverture après
on a un énorme
j'ai dire comme ça ça fait 200 ans que
produire consommer
ça produit du co2 et en fait on a
additionné les couches de co2 avec des
énergies de plus en plus efficaces donc
le bo a d'abord la vapeur ensuite le
pétrole et donc on arrive au point nous
collectivement ça n'est plus supportable
ça n'est plus supportable pour l'avenir
de la planète et quand on voit en plus
que consomme pas ce que produit ou ce
qu'émet en co2 un homme occidental un
homme une femme un d'ailleurs et si on
met tout le monde enfin tout la
population mondiale à haut niveau de
consoles phares d'émissions de co2 là
c'est la fin du monde pour le dire très
brutalement donc on a un énorme
challenge est au fond le capitalisme et
s'est réinventé face à plein de de
mutation faire technologique c est ce qu
internet mais là c'est complètement
différent il faut changer la matrice
après il ya deux solutions il y en a une
qui est efficace on sait d'ailleurs
c'est la décroissance
vous avez vu pendant le confinement on a
arrêté 20 par le vrai premier
confinement là celui voilà donc le
premier confinement
effectivement ça à baisser les émissions
de co2 c'est là on a vu revenir les
animaux dans les centres villes etc non
mais moi je crois que la très très
grande majorité de nos concitoyens est
pas prêt sont pas prêts à arrêter de
voyager consommer bouger et c'est donc
il faut qu'on trouve autre chose alors
l'autre chose c'est une série de
commentaires de deux mesures la première
c'est que il faut taxer le carbone taxer
le carbone ça veut dire quoi il faut que
les les entrepreneurs est un signal prix
que les entreprises un signal prix
qu'ils payent au fond leurs émissions
carbone aujourd'hui une emprise qui
produit jeu pas pour moi du ciment avec
peu de co2 pincer mans ça fait beaucoup
de co2 mais moins de co2 qu'une
entreprise qui produit comme autrefois
il n'y a pas de différence bon c'est
vrai pour les entreprises mais c'est
encore plus vrai pour les consommateurs
aujourd'hui quand vous achetez un
produit pas quoi vous achetez un kiwi
qui vient de nouvelle zélande donc qui a
travaillé qu'à voyager probablement en
avion et c'est donc à contribuer au co2
et vous achetez un kiwi et des kiwis
france est maintenant plus cher fait pas
la différence fait pas la différence il
n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de taxe
carbone la taxe carbone c'est la mère de
toutes les batailles ça qui changera les
comportements après la vente et les
salaires tard de remontée des salaires
pour acheter du kiwi français
attachés oui vous l'aidez si vous
augmentez les salaires vous allez
détruire de l'emploi si on ne sait de
sérier les discussions sur un pay
arriver le deuxième point c'est la
technologie
la technologie c'est hyper important
parce que elles existent aujourd'hui
dans presque tous les secteurs je
parlais du ciment tout à l'heure on
s'est presque faire du ciment sans
émission de co2 sauf que la différence
c'est qu'il coûte beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup alors d'abord il faut investir
massivement et il coûte beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher donc aujourd'hui il
est hors de prix et on ne peut pas le
vendre parce qu'il est enfin j'ai pu le
chiffre en tête mais il est beaucoup
beaucoup le cher simplement on peut se
dire un peu comme les éoliennes ou
l'énergie solaire que au début parce
qu'on en fait pas beaucoup on est à une
courbe de prix enfin niveau de prix qui
est très très élevé puis petit à petit
on peut espérer que si elles amassent ci
a beaucoup de producteurs qui s'y met on
arrive à une technologie qui soit qu'ils
soient efficaces donc il faut investir
dans la technologie
et donc avec cette taxe carbone d'un
côté oui c'est je disais tout à l'heure
qu'on payait trop de taxes moi je suis
prêt à ce qu'on aille vers la taxe
carbone et
les investissements dans la technologie
on peut arriver à garder peut-être pas
le même niveau de consommation parce
qu'il faut une consommation plus sobre
mais en tout cas notre mode de vie
sans fin et en réglant
oui en réglant le problème de la 2 les
émissions de co2 j'ajoute un dernier
point qui est vraiment important on
parle d'émissions de co2 ce qui compte
c'est l'empreinte carbone la différence
je le dire comme ça si on fermait toutes
les usines en europe il y aurait plus
d'émissions donc on aurait résolu pour
on pourrait dire on a réglé le problème
sauf que si on ferme tout des usines en
europe eh ben on va acheter que des
produits qui viennent de pays qui ont
des standards de pollution plus fort et
on n'a rien résolu dans ce qui compte
c'est pas juste les émissions de la
france ou de l'europe c'est l'empreinte
carbone du pays ou de lampes
question internet
la chine n'est pas un concurrent la
chine possède 100% des capacités de
production des microcontrôleurs est ce
que la france a une seule porte de
sortie une seule usine de cp vue
alors je crois là c'est la question un
peu technique en a quand même deux
sociétés qui fabriquent des micros aux
conducteurs des semi-conducteurs il ya
solytek qui est à grenoble si je me
trompe pas et il ya stmicroelectronics
cela étant dit on s'est mis
collectivement par manque de
planification par manque d'entrepreneurs
par manque de plein de choses dans les
mains des chinois notamment alors
cherchez pas coiffée votre intérieur
fait allusion mais le secteur automobile
est extrêmement dépendant de nanopuces
qui viennent de taiwan ait pas de chine
je vais alors vous allez me dire que
taiwan c'est la chine mais là on rentre
sur un autre débat j'ai pas dit non mais
l'embellie parer toute la chine va vous
dire que taiwo j'ai bien compris et il
me parlait il parlait de chine
continentale les mémoires comme je vois
pas le l'e-mail mais oui
l'europe est devenue sur un certain
nombre de produits et de secteurs
dépendantes ou totalement dépendante
de la chine ou d'autres
d'autres est certaine manière le symbole
de tout ça c'est que les masques
vous souvenez et alors pour aller au
bout de la schizophrénie donc
il ya plein de d'entreprise français
temps plein des centaines qui se sont
mis à fabriquer des masques
là il ya eu un appel d'offres
public
et comme la réglementation sur l'appel
que x et ont pris l'appel d'offres
publics et a lieu à 2 centimes le masque
et 2 centimes le masque une enquête
française s'est pas faire bon donc c'est
vrai qu'on est plein de deux je sais pas
comment dire des injonctions
contradictoires de de schizophrénie de 2
voilà on est on est plein de
contradictions
les uns les autres donc ses dépendances
il faut les résoudre le comité
souveraineté économique dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure au medef s'y attelle la
bonne nouvelle quand on sait qu'il ya
une prise de conscience thierry breton
essayer de s'en occuper enfin alors
est-ce qu'on va y arriver il ya quand
même ce projet batterie je sais pas si
vous avez suivi sa l'alliance des
batteries essayer de ne pas dépendre
parce que les batteries électriques
c'est pareil on dépend complètement de
l'asie essayer de ne plus dépendre moins
dépendre mais ça veut dire qu'elles vont
être plus cher donc voilà il ya des
choix de souveraineté qu'il faut faire
que pensez vous de la mise en place
d'une taxe sur la spéculation que
propose par exemple des hommes
politiques je sais pas ce que c'est que
les spéculations j'aurai une taxe sur
les mouvements financiers
alors c'est la ttf taxe sur les
transactions financières et ouais ouais
mais gère spéculation enfin bon je vais
pas commencer à polémiquer sur le mot
mais si vous avez aussi vous vendez
votre appartement ou si vous vendez
votre voiture si vous la vendez plus
cher vous voulez acheter non mais gère
ou si vous vous rendez sur leboncoin ou
sur vinton un truc vous fait de la
spéculation donc ça veut un peu rien
dire les transactions financières
ces supposés les ordres de bourse si la
france met en place cette taxe
évidemment qu'est ce qui va se passer on
est dans une économie mondialisée donc
tous les ordres en bourse vont aller
ailleurs donc il y aura plus d'ordre de
bourse en france il n'ya plus marchés
financiers en france je pas sûr que ce
soit une bonne chose donc le problème de
ce genre d'instrument un qu'on peut
jamais intellectuellement comprendre
c'est que il faudrait qu'il soit mis en
place au même moment dans toutes les
grandes places financières et ça sera
pas le cas ça y aurait un peu plus
largement lui c'est une vraie difficulté
par juste pour élaborer un tout petit
peu sur ce sujet là c'est qu'on est dans
une économie qui est très mondialisé où
les capitaux ben si recul et qu'on met
quand même obligé de prendre en compte
ce qui se passe ailleurs quand on prend
une décision il faut pas simplement
faire comme les autres sinon on tombe
dans la le dob ce qu'on appelle le
dumping fiscal sert chaque pays essaye
de faire moins d'impôts et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous on soutient aussi
c'est un peu étonné on soutient la taxe
minimum donc le bleu combien alors 15 %
d'impôt sur les sociétés 1 aujourd'hui
la france est à 25 donc nous on ne sera
pas concerné mais il nous sommes
raisonnables que toutes les entreprises
du monde paye un minimum d'impôt pour
contribuer à l'éducation aux
infrastructures et comme vous le savez
il ya des endroits des pays y compris au
sein de l'europe y compris au sein
d'europe où les impôts sont beaucoup
plus bas
l'irlande pour le bal a nommé luc way le
plus bas je crois pas pas spécialiste le
n'est pas de filiales en irlande passiez
à luxembourg vous avez fait de l'évasion
fiscale or qu'est ce qu'il pensait de
l'évasion fiscale l'évasion fiscale
c'est illégal et donc ça mérite d'être
condamné et l'optimisation fiscale abbas
est différent en optimisation fiscale
c'est légal alors après lesquels ou c
est légal non c'est légal c'est
l'optimisation fiscale ça consiste
légalement en utilisant les différentes
législations a essayé de payer moins
d'impôts est ce que je peux pour
motoriser a reformulé en utilisant les
différents pôles législation daoui
servante or dans la loire non non non
non pardon non non si vous allez vous
installer général prendre un exemple
très concret quand il y avait les sf qui
a été remplacé par l'ifi on l'arménie et
c'est fou pas atteint les jeunes mais si
vous mettez en paix dans chaque fois
qu'on va pas y arriver quand y avait les
esprits en dégustant du sucre aussi
sinon tout va bien tout va bien je suis
restée résistant et pas pour vous
c'était pour vous reçu
ces termes de torture non ça va ça va
c'est sympa
quand y avait des sf qui était remplacé
par l'ifi il ya des gens à tord ou à
raison on peut les juger moralement
finalement pas patriote a patrie tout ce
que vous voulez qu'ils ont été
s'installer dans un autre pays et ils
ont le droit de le faire on peut pas les
empêcher sauf à faire à mettre un mur
autour de la france où leur retirer leur
nationalité mais pardon mais la
nationalité s'est fait l'avocat du
diable un nom mais quand vous allez
passer dix ans en belgique on n'a pas à
vous retirer ou papa ou en suisse où je
pas où on va pas vous retirer la
nationalité et
ferrari va taxer lent alors ça c'est une
très bonne question oui parce que les
autres n'étaient pas bonnes non mais
cela est technique et là elle me dira
lll un angle qui peut résoudre une
partie des problèmes
il ya les américains ont régi installé
après la guerre grâce à leur puissance
économique l'impôt mondiale voilà ouais
enfin c'est même plus large que ça
disons qu'ils sont riches et installer
l'idée qu'un contribuable américain doit
payer un impôt aux états unis partout
dans le monde et sans malheureusement
aucun pays autre n'a réussi à le faire
moi je ne serais pas choqué qu'on dise
un ressortissant français
installé je sais pas ou que il doit
contrer leur il paye quand même leur
sortie en france l'autre en parenthèse
il paye quand il a un bien immobilier
puisque on a des kids c'est bon pour lui
tu as a way est tout le problème c'est
qu'effectivement le patrimoine et
liquides vous partez avec et donc tout
ça pour dire quoi parce que la preuve ne
sera plus la question d'avoir ces deux
spécialités de servier les questions
oui le système américain est bien que
les américains qui peuvent le mettre en
place voilà donc l'optimisation fiscale
si j'y suis c'est le fait de dire je
vais dans un pays qui me kim comme à
dire qu'ils me taxe moins que si j'étais
dans ceux en france je vous dis pas que
c'est moralement bien
je dis pas que je le ferai j'ai jamais
été dans aucun pays pour des raisons
d'impôts et je le ferai pas et je paye
tous mes impôts en france depuis le
début le début depuis que je puis je
paye des impôts donc c'est un petit
maman qui fait votre déclaration pardon
c'est vous qui faites vous c'est moi qui
la relient
signé quoi et qu'il non non non je la
relis parce que c est suffisamment
complexe en france à vous et ce à
plusieurs pages ça vous a pas échappé un
vrai pas si elle a eu d'expert comptable
lui passe le bonjour d'ailleurs à bong
que tu es très bien
bref tout ça pour dire quoi oui que moi
je n'ai jamais fait mais qu'est ce que
voulez que je vous dise s'il ya des gens
qui pour qui
ils veulent pas payer d'impôts c'est
leur liberté c'est leur droit et voilà
je n'ai pas d'avis avant là dessus et il
n'y a pas de moyens la concurrence
fiscale ça existe pour ça qu encore une
fois la bonne solution le patriotisme
fiscal est ce que ça existe
moi je vais d'ailleurs bénéficié d'une
éducation à voir ou à initier de
sécurité avoir bénéficié de nos beaux
paysages avoir bénéficié de notes
hôpital qui est en train de crever d
avoir bénéficié de nos pompiers nous
infirmiers ères d'eau prof notre système
éducatif
on doit expliquer un dvd fiscal que riez
pas d'évadés l'évadé ça n'existe pas ça
les valait on s'évade d'une prison donc
ce n'est pas une prison la france sauf
j'espère pas à l'expliquer un mec qui
habite la belgique ou la suisse pour
vous que il faut qu'il rentre en france
pour payer plus d'impôts qui sauve le
pays mais pardon il va il va pas entrer
dans cette discussion il va dire moi je
paye 100 et demain vous me nommez payer
200 et en plus il va dire probablement
bah oui en plus et 200 ils sont mal
utilisés les fonctionnaires font si
machin ses talons le débat il est
comment dire ça chacun fait chacun a sa
propre confiance donc moi je paye mes
impôts en france j'en paye plein donc je
suis atteint ben je paye l'ifi je paye
l'impôt sur le revenu en fonction de mes
dividende
je paye des taxes d'habitation enfin
voilà quoi je paye je paye tout ce que
je dois payer face on n'est pas des
discussions possibles est-ce que c'est
du patriotisme fiscales non c'est juste
obéir à la loi après j'ai pas envie
d'habiter à l'étranger pour des raisons
de fric parce que comme vous le savez la
france oui j'aime la france j'aime ce
pays puis j'aime bien bouffer français
ben voilà à quoi je vis au corps ouais
mais vous pouvez pas obliger quelqu'un à
aimer la france mais c'est pour revenir
sur le patrice escale si un gars qui
préfèrent un gars ou un filet qui
préfèrent vivre ailleurs qui secoue les
faire vais pas lui pas la seule solution
c'est mettre un mur
c'est le sert et à la douane oui ben
c'est pareil fête vire de m'établir ce
l'empêcher de partir chez leur entrée
mais pourquoi la précédente référence et
vous pouvez pas interdire quelqu'un vous
interdit pas un anglais de venir en
france peut pas interdire un français
c'est quand même curieux de 2 comme
raisonnement parce que vous qui a dû
dire s'il vous plaît mais mais non là
n'est alors après la déchéance de
nationalité pour quelqu'un qui hier
décidé d'aller vivre machin papillon
plus la différence faire la différence
entre celui qui a choisi de vivre
en belgique pour la fiscalité celui qui
a choisi de vivre en belgique parce que
ibos en belgique c'est quand même pas
évident gestion question du petit victor
mais pas au nom connais pas non plus y
mettre le salaire des femmes au même
niveau de celui des hommes a financé lui
le régime des retraites alors je pense
pas que ça financera quoi que ce soit
mais par contre c'est un vrai combat qui
reste encore à poste équivalent des
différences et ça tombe bien la france a
mis en place un outil qui s'est révélé
très efficace qui est en train de se
révéler très efficace qui hélas d'aix
égalité homme femme qui a
obligatoirement depuis
deux ans maintenant et deux ans je ne
trompe pas dans toutes les sociétés de
plus de 50 salariés parce qu'il faut
quand même un petit échantillon pour
pouvoir comparer parce que évidemment
c'est un poste comparable et qui en
train d'avoir un effet
très rapide sur les cas qui existe
indiscutablement où il ya pour le même
poste avec la même ancienneté tahir faut
tout comparer géant les mêmes cours de
qualification ne sera donc pas juste
dire
des rattrapages de salaires qui qu'il
faut faire il faut faire de la
discrimination positif au niveau des
salaires pour les femmes
alors non non pour les salaires faut
juste faire ne s'est pas de la
discrimination qu'il faut faire du
rattrapage chez ou non mais le
rattrapage c'est bien beau parce que ça
fait des années qu'elles dégustent quand
même est-ce qu'il faut pas se rattraper
un peu plus vite en mettant plus tout de
suite mais plus que les hommes que les
hommes maintenant il ya pas de raison de
payer les femmes plus que les hommes
c'est absurde alors il faut simplement
faire ce qu'on aurait dû faire et en
fait cet index il a servi à quoi au fond
il a servi à révéler aux drh au patron
et c'est des choses qui ne savaient pas
qu'ils avaient ou dont il s'occupait pas
maintenant il ya une loi et de tension
de temps voilà ça fait du bien question
internet que pense-t-il quand le
gouvernement fait appel à des sociétés
privées étrangères pour des conseils tu
as c'est une très bonne question je sais
pas si c'est victor dont ces populations
de bouki de doki doki mais enfin je ne
peux pas féliciter de kim et je le
félicite à l'écran ouais c'est un sujet
dans les sujets
[Musique]
de souveraineté
et de naïveté qu'on a évoqué au début il
ya parfois
l'utilisation
de conseil ou de ta de société je prends
un exemple d'air peu connus que sont les
courtiers en assurance un courtier en
assurances a pas le courtier
d'assurances qui assure votre bagnole
mais le courtier en assurances de très
grandes boîtes ce sont évidemment des
gens qui vont connaît énormément de
choses sur l'entreprise
ils ont beaucoup de la maison puisque un
courtier en assurances il faut imaginer
ce que c'est qu'une très grande prise il
ya des usines ya donc ils ont tous le
finalement ils ont tout le panorama de
l'entreprise et donc ça fait partie des
gens qui est renseignements économique
de lente dans l'entreprise alors je ne
suis pas en train de vous dire que
systématiquement ces informations sont
utilisées etc mais je pense qu'il faut
être prudent il faut 7 l'un fait
attention une petite fosse est de quoi
que vous dites ils ne font pas tout le
temps du renseignement et colomina mais
je vois c'est à l'insu de leur plein gré
mais je vois bien le prix ce que vous
avez fait là qu'on en fait fâché de voir
nos entreprises françaises en doji ouais
mais pardon j'ai bien compris votre
prisme j'ai bien compris et vous avez
raison mais ne tombez parfum devons bien
faites comme vous voulez mais il faut
pas tomber du mauvais côté de penser
qu'à chaque fois contre avec un étranger
à chaque fois qu'on commerce avec un
étranger à chaque fois qu'on voit signé
un accord on va se faire par non excusez
moi de le dire baiser parce qu'ils sont
tous à la solde de la cia ou du kgb non
là la vie est un peu plus complexe sur
le marché pardon n'a pas qu sur les eaux
du mossad ou de ou de stratus sur le
marché même les belges font une
intelligence et que lui même jamais
jamais oui mais y'a comme fois je vous
dis pas que ça n'existe au milieu cloud
ou d'ailleurs je vous dis pas que ça
n'existe pas je ne dis pas que mais je
devine le monde des affaires ne tournent
pas uniquement autour de ça parce qu'il
n'ya pas une carence ou l'intelligence
économique
france alors ça c'est une autre bonne
question ça fait 2 c'est bien j'ai posé
plus de questions continuent à provoquer
je veux dire franchement mais change
tout va bien
béret vert jean longeot matin après on
verra ça à la sortie comme
attendu coup c'était quoi oui est ce
qu'il ya une carence entre oui d'abord
je pense qu'il ya une histoire de
culture d'histoire de ne sais pas
comment dire de oued de tradition table
c'est au père guillaume bernard esambert
alors et lambert weegee homo je vois pas
qui c'est anne guillaumat guillaume ou
hspa qui est guy aubert non mais je suis
désolé je ne vais pas je sèche
ouais il ya
l'air le mot intelligence a traduit
voilà on s'est donc les anglo saxons
historiquement pour plein de raisons que
c'est peut-être difficile à expliquer
qu'ils doivent remonter à l'histoire à
la culture etc ont une tradition à dire
d'espionnage ou de renseignement comme
voulait plus forte que nous petit à
petit 2 c'est vécu comme un métier
prestigieux
et est comment dire considérée comme une
métier noble ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez nous et donc à partir de là c'est
vrai qu' il n'y a pas cette tradition là
dans toutes les entreprises françaises
même les grandes j'espère que c'est en
train de changer en tout cas on essaie
d'y contribuer
alors dans les grandes je pense que
maintenant voilà il ya j'ai pas cité
dans près sans cesse enfin toutes les
entreprises qui sont dans des sphères
que j'appellerais régaliennes à
l'énergie l'armement et c'est
bon il ya ce qu'il faut si j'ose dire
après je pense qu'il ya vous n'êtes pas
d'accord mais moi je pense qu'elle est
ce qu'il faut en donner des
gages ça vous parle oui
le pegasus bridge
je vous dis quelque chose de pegasus
bridge je vous écoute même pegasus
bridge donc le 6 juin 44
il ya ce pont qui est juste derrière
ouistreham à tous quoi là ils doivent
tenir dans le film le 6 juin 42 le jour
j vous ne vous souvenez pas ils
attendent et ils tiennent le pont
jusqu'à qu'arrivent les bérets verts de
leurs bleus battent avec la cornemuse
donc pegasus bridge
voilà après pourquoi ils ont fait ça
pegasus jeu ce logiciel je sais pas mais
oui tout le monde a été victime de
pegasus à tout le monde oui enfin
beaucoup de gens étaient victimes de
pegasus donc si le principe je vous
amène sur ce sujet pourrait oui enfin je
connais principe en sécurité
informatique en sécurité informatique
beaucoup ça faire des portes blindées
extraordinaire
inviolable par contre le mur en carton
pâte tout autour de la porte blindée
quand il ya des méchants pirates ou des
hackers qui font le pentest on passe
avec un cutter ou une cuillère à peine
affûté et aux découpes le mur en carton
et la super portes blindées elle tombe
par terre est-ce qu'il faut pas penser
en dehors de la boîte en termes de
sécurité en termes d'intelligence
économique pour ma part dans ces deux
choses comme un poil différent tout ce
qui est cybersécurité
cyberdéfense menaces de type
hacker ou
pegasus benes de type pirates pirates
voulaient pas drôle pirates ou des
raisons pirates ou ou pegasus je pense
qu'on est on est très très mal équipé
dans le film un pont trop loin non non
non sapin 3 ça se passe en hollande mais
quand tu t'es trompé victoire je suis
désolé victor non non non je parle bien
du jour j le pegasus bridge un bon bref
donc du coup oui je fais la différence
de l'intelligence économique qu'ils
aient la capacité qu'on a à utiliser des
moyens soient ouverts parce que c'est
souvent ouverts l'intelligence
économique soit plus clandestins pour
obtenir l'information sur son concurrent
c'est pas une tradition française ça
n'est pas notre culture je pense que les
très grandes entreprises dans le domaine
régalien sont équipés peut-être pas
assez par contre sur la cyber disons-le
à la protection des les murs en carton
là vous évoquez oui on est à poil nous
on a fait avec le dg si
excrétas date amérique on a créé un
numéro d' alerte cyber donc et un petit
truc qui en sont nos 170 mille
entreprises on a un sms qui par
sms ou un mail qui dit attention ce truc
est un phishing fait gaffe etc mais bon
c'est de la protection de de gea dire de
ça protège de pas grand chose quoi ça
protège d'un peu de demandes de rançons
enfin j'en sais rien moi j'ai pas un
expert de la cie mer mais si vous vécu
sion des fours les plages françaises
sont un poil devant les menaces himer
oui probablement oui aux emplois futurs
nos emplois futurs ce pas juste les
miens nous nos emplois futurs si vous
êtes patriote c'est sûr nous emploient
comme un doute là dessus non mais c'est
pour ça que je dis nos emplois futurs
donc nos emplois futurs oui ça fait
partie des menaces mais elle a plein
d'autres mais oui ils sont ils sont en
jeu en tout cas dans un dans des
domaines parce qu'il ya dans les cyber
ya quand même deux types de menaces il
ya les menaces de type chantage argent
en somme - air etc oula bon c'est juste
un coup financier je dis pas que c'est
et puis aller voler les menaces
d'espionnage qui vont entre guillemets
aller chercher des secrets de
fabrication pour utiliser pour un
concurrent question de sam qui
d'ailleurs en résonance avec ce qu'on a
à me dire affaires alstom j'aime plus
photonis quand est ce que le medef va
s'emparer du problème de la guerre
économique plutôt que de faire du
lobbying pour ne pas augmenter le smic
d'abord on peut faire les deux si je
puis me permettre en plus le sans-pareil
sais pas ce que ça veut dire sans pareil
du sujet des guerres économiques nous on
n'est pas une agence de renseignement
n'est pas vous n'êtes pas une agence de
renseignement d'accord parce que ok mais
quand vous voyez que vous êtes un peu en
short elle est la moindre des choses
c'est d'essayer de se mettre un petit
élastique quand même donc vous avez fait
votre petite application sms pour hier
attention ça c'est du phishing des
chaumières c'est cool mais quand il ya
des gens qui le font pas vous n'êtes pas
trop vous savez ce qu'il faut faire vous
faites des médias sortez les doigts vous
sortez les doigts vous montez votre pote
votre propre cellule mais si vous n'êtes
pas aidé il faut arrêter de compter sur
l'état pendant le medef est pas là pour
monter une pas quoi une agence
dangereusement une cellule a ni les
moyens financiers ni là c'est pas notre
vocation nous on est là pour faire
comprendre aux entreprises les enjeux de
demain les enjeux d'aujourd'hui ça c'est
les sujets de lobbying qu'évoquer votre
internaute les enjeux de demain dia la
transition qu'on ait évoqué il ya
effectivement leur faire prendre
conscience que les risques cyber les
risques d'espionnage existe et qu'une
fois on a créé ce comité on a fait des
dizaines de webinars je pense que la
confiance
des patrons français de toutes tailles
de toutes tailles d'entreprises a
progressé est ce qu'elle est au bon
niveau de niveau de la menace jeu
probablement pas qu'est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse plus oui mais ne troll c'est
pas d'aller dans les entreprises on n'a
pas les mêmes familles et les moyens ni
la paire cessé il ya 150 personnes au
medef un gérant pas
le fonctionnement de combien 40e 38
entre 38 et 40 millions mais on a des
gens qui s'occupent de fiscalité on a
des gens qui s'occupent de salaire le
plus élevé au medef ces qui bien c'est
pas bien ce que moi je suis bénévole
mais dont je pas payer donc
et donc c'est le directeur général qui
doit être entre je pense 250 300 mille
euros
art brut
vous me posez une colle weaver va me
bruts salariale quoi
oui ça doit être ça ray on va parler
croissance un peu écologie tout ça il ya
pas très longtemps
fait une interview d'une géologue sur
les techniques minières on a parlé de
l'épuisement de certaines matières
premières
sécurisation de de certaines matières
premières en terme d'écologie en termes
de consommation de matières premières
votre serveur première question le
scénario du medef c'est quoi c'est plus
simple de plus 3 + 4 degrés n'est pas de
scénario du medef dont se fait en sont
en écoute les scientifiques en écoute le
giec en voilà on a pas et on n'a ni
l'expertisé ni lé nous la seule chose
qu'on peut faire c'est prendre la
science tels que les données à le
consensus scientifique et là dessus il
ya un consensus alors il ya quelques
exceptions enfin on va dire qu'il ya un
consensus mondial assez fort c'est quoi
les quelques exceptions elles vous
entendez de temps en temps des gares et
sur internet qui sont climato sceptiques
il on nous raconte des conneries etc
mais bon comme voilà bon comme sur tous
les sujets scientifiques vous avez
toujours quelqu'un qui parce que ça fait
du buzz qui va dire le contraire donc
c'est prendre ces informations face au
consensus scientifique et voir comment
avec nos moyens avec les entreprises
leurs capacités d'investissement on peut
réduire les émissions des entreprises
françaises donc à quelle vitesse on fait
comment ce qu'on le fait qu'elles sont
les stimuli et c'est
sur les matières premières
oui c'est un très gros sujet c'est un
sujet géostratégique qui détient
ensemble de matières premières le
lithium par exemple c'est le chili je
crois qu'il un des principaux pays qui
détient du lithium
ça va être une ressource rare parce
qu'on fait migrer tout le monde à
l'électrique voiture électrique à toute
vitesse donc on va se retrouver dans un
comment dire dans une dépendance à des
pays qui ont du lithium qui va nous
poser certainement des problèmes
voilà donc et dont on peut débattre
alors vous savez pas si vous avez eu
l'interview qui était assez intéressant
de les patrons de ce talent this
peugeot citroën fiat sur les
conséquences sociales que ça l'est oui
alors les conséquences sociales dans mes
10 et 2 choisi d y a des conséquences
sociales qu'on n'a pas évalué mais ils
disent et surtout
sur la baisse des émissions de co2 il
est prendre plus utile d'avoir des
voitures hybrides à très faible
consommation autour de 2 litres ou
kilomètres plutôt que de migrer à toul
électrique puisque je crois je me
souviens du chiffre la joue le site de
mémoire c'est au bout de soixante dix
mille kilomètres qu'une qu'une voiture
électrique si on prend son cycle de vie
complet y compris donc ce qu'elle a
coûté en fabrication les métaux rares et
c est un bilan écologique plus enfin
meilleur que une voiture hybride mais la
législation pour le moment on a décidé
autrement le medef y voit comment la
décroissance
on la voit je moi je n'ai forcé jeunes
entre guillemets crois pas la
décroissance est la solution ultime et
là je vous dis ok boomer si vous voulez
oui bah ça je suis boomers je suis en 62
donc je suis 100% bühler qu il connaît
des vues qui sont très je demeure tête
quand même mais moi je si vous voulez là
la question est très simple c'est est ce
que les français ou les européens sont
prêts à décroître pour laisser les
africains les asiatiques enfin ceux qui
sont en retard au niveau de vie croître
réalité si vous demandez aux gens
peut-être comme les sondages vous avez
10 % qu'ils vont vous dire oui mais dans
leurs comportements quotidiens confère
d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes dans la
vraie vie les gens ont envie de
consommer alors qu'on puisse trouver une
moyenne un moyen de le rendre plus sobre
la consommation il y a effectivement
énormément de gâchis quand vous voyez
enfin bon on peut citer plein de came
donc on peut améliorer l'impact
environnemental de la consommation mais
je crois pas les croissances ce que je
vais leur part comme je crois pas que ça
soit un scénario acceptable par les
populations la seule chose qu'on peut
imaginer c'est que ce soit la solution
ultime si on n'arrive pas à faire une
croissance moins consommatrices
d'énergie moins consommatrices de m
haies première c'est ça le sujet c'est
comment on fait le ciment c'est un super
exemple parce que le ciment je crois que
c'est le plus gros sa fin dans
l'industrie c'est le plus gros émetteur
de co2 bon donc on va pas tous remplacés
par du bois partout
donc est ce qu'on arrive à faire du
ciment zéro carbone à quel coût est ce
que une maison construite avec du ciment
zéro carbone on pourrait la vendre un
peu plus cher enfin c'est vrai c'est
laisser le sinon effectivement faudra
plus construire de maisons et ça pose
plein de problèmes de vie aux gens et
c'est
christian internet est ce qu'il peut
nous dire qu'ils sont nos amis dans ce
monde selon lui personne
question suivante non alors non je vais
vous dire les choses un peu différemment
pour développer un peu il ya des gens
c'est comme danser comme dans une
famille vous avez votre famille proche
et des cousins un peu lointain vous
voyez de temps en temps pour y en a avec
qui vous entendre il y en a qui rien à
vous avez un peu honte d'autres achats
et puis après vous avez vous connaissez
pas avoir donc il ya des cercles
concentriques donc on est quand même
plus proche des européens partagent plus
de choses plus de valeur d'abord on a
plus en commun on aime ce que j'ai et à
l'air on a quand même un système quand
vous allez en allemagne et que vous
tombez malade vous êtes quand même
soigner un peu comme en france voilà il
ya des hôpitaux les prix sont pas allés
aux états unis à new york et ses 68
dollars pour vous faire j'sais pas quoi
une opération qui qui coûte enfin qui
coûte pendant le même prix en france
mais dans le prix payé par le client
final est beaucoup moins cher donc
on perçoit la
commande il ya on n'a pas
d'amis complètement alignés vous le
savez les allemands qui pensaient que
les américains et leurs amis ont
découvert que angela merkel son
téléphone était espionné ça c'était en
piquant il ouais enfin il ya quelques
années voilà donc
on n'a pas d'amis je les cite l heure c
on n'a que des intérêts il faut trouver
le bon niveau entre coopération et
compétition
pour venir il ya la personne qui
apparaît avec qui nous a posé la
question sur les cpu qui nous fait un
petit commentaire voilà autorisé mais
bien sûr est mais pour interrogation on
n'a pas de concurrent on aime n'est pas
concurrent d'un monstre comme la chine
nous n'avons aucune mine de cobalt
aucune usine en alsace de smartphones
aucune usine de bagnols juste des
saucissons et entre parenthèses et non
même la cedh et un port bulgare fermer
la parenthèse de quelle concurrence par
le tea là il est un peu déclinistes
votre ami je prie commercial al-maliki
lice ils travaillent au québec et c'est
une brute de chez brut mamede clinisud
et recense pessimiste du dr n'est pas
pessimiste s'il fait l'avocat du diable
bon si vous voulez
et à la france encore des terreaux
d'excellence gis à l'aéronautique les
avoirs ingère c'est un duo paul
aujourd'hui mondiale enfin quasi duo
paul part exagérée mais quasi duopole
entre airbus et boeing et depuis deux
ans airbus taille plutôt des croupières
à boeing zae le luxe peut considérer que
c'est pas un secteur important n'empêche
que on a des emprises de luxe et des
cosmétiques en france qui sont
extrêmement puissante leaders mondiaux
bon vous avez alors ça paraît bizarre de
dire ça se d'ex-hauts même s'ils sont un
peu de difficulté avec le co vider le
télétravail c'est leader mondial de la
restauration collective et c'est donc
faut pas non plus se dire les chinois
ont tout et on n'y arrivera pas oui on a
un concurrent extrêmement puissant
qu'est des avantages compétitifs énorme
qui a un système économique où ils ont
pas de gilet jaune parce que quand il ya
des gels et jaune voilà donc
on est sur un autre modèle c'est un
modèle où c'est compliqué de d'être en
compétition mais il faut pas se dire que
la la comment dire la guerre la course
est finie ou la compétition et dans
l'autre sens certains autres trucs les
américains tolère je disais ils ont un
système unique pour créer des champions
des google etc mais en technologies vous
le savez sûrement mieux que moi ça va
vite
et pas si vous souvenez on parlait de
mes rejeté hoblyn ans réseaux sociaux la
sociale
vocale qui était le hype ya un an
surtout qu'ils jouent mais je me suis un
peu comment ça s'appelait mes
conseillers en com comme vous dites
qu'ils voulaient absolument que je fasse
un intrus que chez eux bon ils ont
disparu jusque vers c'est qu'il ya des
eip et quand google est né il y avait
des dizaines de réseaux sociaux asss de
moteur de recherche ask jeeves tous ces
trucs là ça ou lycos tout ça ça a
disparu donc bien là la guerre
économique dans laquelle elle nécessaire
d'avoir un moteur de recherche un
européen français abbas est nécessaire
que google n'est plus son monopole c'est
ça le sujet est requis moi je pense j'ai
écrit dans les échos il ya arrêt il ya
vraiment longtemps que genre 7 8 ans je
pense qu'à un moment
une autorité de régulation
européennes ou américaines mais plutôt
européenne comprend des coupes rang
alors tu es coupera ça fait un peu mais
c'est parra comme en fait tu sais pas si
vous vous souvenez vous souvenez pas
mais dans les années 50 le tas peu
désagréable souvenez peut-être en lisant
les livres d'histoire dans les années 50
at enti donc été le monopole télécom
donc c'était les ptt en fait américains
ont été découpée en six ou sept sociétés
régionales parce qu'il fixe et un tarif
et qu'ils avaient un monopole donc c'est
un peu cette logique là qui un jour je
pense s'appliquera et donc oui il faut
qu'il y ait des moteurs de recherche à m
il faut tous les marchés y ait une offre
le problème c'est l'offre elle a parlé
brièvement du clad là pour revenir là
dessus il ya une offre de clubs
européens français qui ovh non
aujourd'hui premier fonds de chiffre
d'affaires mais qui est plus une petite
start up qui est pas encore à la taille
suffisante nous on a fait venir les gens
de vh plein de fois on les a oui papa
octave non son dg paulin parce que c'est
plutôt paulin qui fait le commander
enfin publique rai les jeunes en quelque
sorte bon on l'a fait venir on l'a fait
intervenir dans plein de domaines de
souveraineté on essaie de convaincre les
grandes boîtes de de prendre ovh donc là
c'est un marché où il n'y a pas encore
de lio paul ya trois concurrents
américains donc on est encore dans une
bataille qu'on peut gagner le belle
bataille du moteur de recherche
compliqué edf qui se fait un peu
administré par le parti communiste chine
comment ça s'appelle le web
le début eu des fdf qui se fait
administrer par le parti communiste un
peu comme en chine l'a
obligé de vendre son aîné avait pendant
vos choix et vos liens avec le parti
communiste mais on reste une boutade on
s'est compris ils sont obligés de vendre
leur électricité pas cher à leurs
propres concurrents
sénat lequel que ça et chemise en
acheter sur le marché une chaire ben ali
pour revendre moins cher alors c'est que
le beurre la crémière la vache tout y
passe alors ouais mais alors bon ça
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que ce travail
alors c'est vraiment un sujet compliqué
je vais être obligé d'être un peu
technique premier tour avec dix
centrales à l'arrêt voilà premier point
c'est ce que j'allais vous dire on a un
premier problème c'est que on n'a pas
investi dans le nucléaire depuis 20 ans
et donc on arrive à un moment où le
nucléaire est devenu presqu'une été
rejeté remis tente comme les éoliennes
et comme le solaire c'est alors c'est un
peu bizarre de dire ça mais comme il ya
60% du parc et qui est actif aujourd'hui
et qui ça risque de continuer on a
finalement des énergies intermittentes
alors que justement le nucléaire était
là pour compenser l'intermittence des
énergies intermittentes que sont
l'éolien et le solaire bon petit à petit
le il ya un marché de l'électricité qui
a été conçu par
bon les jambes bruxelles avec le fait
que c'est le prix de l'énergie marginal
qui fait le prix du marché terre c'est
le dernier mégawattheure de gaz qui fait
le prix de tout le marché et donc le
prix de marché a explosé parce qu'il ya
une tension sur le gaz russe avant
l'ukraine et depuis depuis maintenant
quatre cinq mois et dernière chose il ya
eu cette volonté de libéraliser le
marché en forçant edf à revendre de la
capacité en bloquant le niveau là mais
jamais il était imaginé qu'elle vendrait
en dessous de son prix de revient ce
quelqu'un que du coup il a maintenant
cessé et après il ya le dernier point
qui est la schizophrénie de l'état qui
est d'un côté actionnaires à
85% de
d'edf et de l'autre donc les 8 milliards
de pertes de valeur qu'ils créent par
par cette mesure c'est l'état
actionnaire passer tous les actionnaires
mais dix ans l'état principalement
subventions déguisées en fait alors
c'est une subvention acquis pas au pas
aux alternatifs parce qu'ils n'arrivent
soit obligé de repasser le prix aux
industriels c'est une subvention aux
industriels qu'ils consomment ce qu'on
appelle les energo intensif qui
consomment beaucoup d'électricité est en
fait le problème c'est qu'à 200 ont été
montés à 3 250 euros le mégawattheure le
ya des usines qui allait fermer une
usine d'aluminium notamment l'aluminium
sa consomment beaucoup d'électricité
donc on était pris enfin le gouvernement
était pris dans un espèce de dilemne
infernal avec les règles européennes qui
sont celles qu'elles sont de soi laisser
fermer ses usines ce qui était une
catastrophe pour plein de raisons soit
de pénaliser df quitte aussi une
catastrophe la seule réponse possible la
réponse de court terme y en a pas c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait maladroitement et la
réponse de long terme c'est de changer
les règles du marché électricité
européens qui ne peut pas dépendre
uniquement du dernier prix du gaz russe
par une gaze mais essentiellement du gaz
russe qui a tort ou à raison
évidemment un élément de pression assez
fort question internet
comment pense-t-il que les grandes
entreprises vont s'adapter au déclin du
pétrole entre parenthèses qui est déjà
amorcé
[Musique]
ça dépend un peu du type d'entreprises
comme vous êtes l'oréal prix du pétrole
joue peu vous avez un peu d'énergie dans
vos usines star mais c'est pas un
facteur un peu je sais pas quoi le
plastique des shampoings star mais quand
vous êtes total
et que le pétrole représente l'essentiel
de vos profits vous faites quoi vous
faites ce que fait puyané et j'espère
pour lui que ça va marcher je perds pour
la france aussi d'ailleurs que vous vous
appelez total nrj vous achetez comme des
malades
deschamps d'éolien des fermes solaires
pour essayer de migrer le plus vite
possible avec les profits du pétrole
pour financer les achats d'énergie
nouvelle mais c'est une stratégie
c'est un peu la stratégie qui avait fait
des groupes textiles dans les années 60
quoi c'est à dire je pars en courant
d'une industrie qui est en train de de
disparaître pour essayer d'aller sur une
industrie connexes qui est en train
d'émerger alors ça c'est une question
provoque et revoit à peu près de
quelques courants politiques sa part
l'euro va quand même la pause et
medef égale mouvement des entreprises de
france c'est ça que reste-t-il des
français dans les positions européiste
défendue par le medef que reste-t-il des
français dans les positions occupées
lice du français de la langue aux 2,2
que reste-t-il de français dans les pins
adieu français dans les positions
européen défendue par le medef
parce que votre internautes appellent
des positions européiste
nous remet effectivement favorables à
l'europe au sens large à l'europe
politique tout en étant extrêmement
consciente de ses difficultés à
commencer par l'élargissement qui a posé
énormément de problèmes
est ce qu'on essaie de défendre les
intérêts français au sein des intérêts
européens ben oui oui alors est ce qu on
le fait bien j'en sais rien je venais un
exemple
assez récent c'est le nucléaire les
allemands alors je parle delà de ce qui
s'appelle business europe business
europe c'est
j'en veux bien mais si je pouvais pas
parler donc tout
business europe c'est le média fonds
européens pour faire simple bon il ya
les allemands sont très puissants il ya
nous il ya les italiens paient tout le
monde quoi bomber les allemands ils
poussaient pour que le gaz soit classé
énergie de transition dans la à ce qu'on
appelle la taxonomie le classement des
énergies et nous ont poussés pour le
nucléaire et donc on a essayé de fédérer
les polonais les tchèques enfin semble
deux pays qui des suédois aussi qu'ils
sont pro nucléaire action l'énergie
nucléaire et on avait en face de nous
une coalition de pays qui étaient elles
pro gazon en tout cas antinucléaires
donc de temps en temps on a des intérêts
communs de temps en temps des intérêts
divergents et on essaye de ceux de se
bagarrer question internet de théodule
c'est un peu le comité théodule ça peut
être un pseudonyme mais en
le secteur automobile européen qui
s'associe avec des boîtes us du
numérique quelle est la stratégie
je pense qu'il fait allusion à l'accord
entre ce talent tisser google il me
semble inquiet
je ne connais pas le contenu de l'accord
mais je pense alors c'est difficile de
répondre à la place du patron de psa
sans savoir savent et son numéro de
téléphone du patron de psa oui mais j'ai
pas l'appeler pour lui demander il
faudra nous donner son numéro non je
vous donne ma façon numéro votre
téléphone est où mon téléphone portable
n'en voulait pas encore à quai il est
juste
du coup je sais plus mais la question
c'est que aujourd'hui s'allier avec 1
entre guillemets un fournissent européen
numérique il prend qui aujourd'hui les
systèmes d'exploitation il a deux comme
vous le savez il ya android et donc
google et apple donc si vous voulez
mettre du numérique dans la voiture vous
avez pas tellement choix d'ailleurs
historiquement je crois pas me tromper
psa est d'ailleurs d'autres
constructeurs notamment volkswagen ont
essayé de développer leur propre système
d'exploitation pour ce qu'on appelle
l'infotainment c'est à dire le
l'électronique dans la voiture ce que le
ski adam l'écran à la fois le meut le
mapping la musique les films etc et puis
finalement comme il ya une domination
sans partage les systèmes d'exploitation
android d'un côté et apple de l'autre
ils n'ont pas eu le choix donc on en
revient finalement la réponse à votre
votre internaute fin la question qui
pose c'est les monopoles mondiaux
essentiellement américains en
technologie et comment faire en sorte
qu'il y ait des concurrents européens
français si possible qui émerge jeu
désolé jugé encore de lire un
commentaire de notre ami qui au canada
mais
l'allemagne a des banques industriels
qui s'engagent elles pas avec du capital
civile à nouveau de quoi parle-t-il
atteint à l'item aux états unis les
conditions de levée de fonds sont très
différentes de la france quand il brille
dès les bancs bourgeoise et aider les
pme innovantes carbone par exemple
vont-elles l'écouté
on relit parce que je n'ai pas tout
compris l'allemagne à des banques
industrie qui s'engagent elles pas avec
du capital civile à nouveau de quoi
parle-t-il idem aux états unis les
conditions de levée de fonds sont très
différents de la france compte il brider
les banques bourgeoise
et aider les pme innovantes carbone par
exemple bon que tu es là j'ai pas
complètement tout compris va je pense
qu'avec le capitalisme en gros ce qu'il
dit c'est que le trouver de l'argent
c'est plus facile quand on innove aux
états unis je suis d'accord avec lui un
système financier qui est tous ses
défauts mais on sait qu'il a quand même
généré la crise de 2008 ne faut pas
oublier ceux non plus mais
il a quand même une capacité à prendre
des risques est plus forte qu'en europe
sur l'allemagne c'est un peu différent
je sais pas ce qu'il a en tête mais en
allemagne qui a un tissu industriel plus
fort qui exportent qui est un solde
comme vous le savez d'excédent
commercial e positive depuis des années
à plus de 200 milliards dans ce qui fait
la force de l'allemagne c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mittelstand crc des
entreprises familiales à capitaux
familiaux sans intervention extérieure
qui sont ce qu'on appelle les hôtes
évident que les entreprises à taille
intermédiaire grosses pme on va dire que
des pme de 100 200 300 500 millions
c'est ça qui nous manque
on a là je crois la moitié à peu près
5000 en france on a dix à douze mille en
allemagne la différence elle se fait
plus sûres non pas les grands groupes à
ce que nos grands groupes sont de taille
mondiale assez compétitifs ses aînés tpe
ben c'est pareil c'est entre les deux
questions de 10 lot
santé microsoft éducation
microsoft armée microsoft arméno sncf à
double less amazon les membres du
gouvernement font de la pub pour les
gars femmes avec des maillots de foot
google les règles d'attribution de
marché favorisant les gars femme sans
laisser la chance aux entreprises
françaises ou européennes ça c'est la
réalité de terrain ils trouvent ça
normal on fait quoi contre ça
te fait le medef
d'abord j'ai encore une fois on est 150
t on n'est pas en charge de tous et moi
je suis pas ministre sauf je pense pas
moi qui soit en charge du gouvernement
donc c'est pas moi qui joue avec un
match devait un maillot de foot je sais
c'est quoi le maillot de foot
ouh ah oui non mais ça c'est le nom du
ministre mais le nom du maillot de fans
le nom du lot gauche puisque c'était bon
bref
non mais il a raison d'une certaine
manière est là l'europe nous handicape à
l'europe au sens institutionnel
parce que les règles des appels d'offres
publics notamment interdisent de faire
ce que font les américains vous savez
que il ya un buy american act qui est
qui qui est très ancien qui date je peux
dire de bêtises mais je crois de la fin
des années 50 qui permet de privilégier
notamment les pme américaines dans les
marchés publics
nous au medef on milite c'est dans nos
programmes qu'on a mis en ligne pour la
présidence en fin pour les élections
présidentielles un bail européenne actes
on va voir la réciprocité prem qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet en plus j'en ai
parlé ce matin avec un commissaire
européen c'est que il ya des petits pays
on est à 27 c l'unanimité il ya des
petits pays qui sont contre r au passage
c'est un des vrais sujets de l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut que pour la
plupart des décisions il ya unanimité et
donc vous avez toujours quelqu'un pour
lever la main ont souvent un petit pays
dont les intérêts ne coïncide pas avec
des grands pays industriels cette règle
de l'unanimité qui a été fait par de
gaulle quand on était six et pour les
intérêts français il faut se souvenir
comment ça a été construit
63 64 il ya la mise en place de la
politique agricole commune la france est
une grosse agriculture l'allemagne
grosse industrie et donc il dit ben il
faut qu'on soit tous les six d'accord
donc c'est mon droit de veto je vais
l'appeler que la chaise vide tant que
vous mettez pas mes conditions mais on
était six arrivées six pays donc à six
dont la france était elle même si
l'allemagne de l'ouest donc la france
était le plus puissante la plus grosse
de l'époque je n'ai pas dit ça mais
c'était une autre époque en tout cas et
donc du coup cette règle limitée à 27
elle est juste intenable elle est
intenable parce que ça veut dire que
malte j'ai rien contre les maltais ou le
luxembourg a le même pouvoir que
l'allemagne la france l'italie ça pose
un problème
de fonctionnement énorme quoi
que pense-t-il je viens verre d'eau
quand même à maman wind bière mais vous
amène sa lé bien
d'autres et que pense-t-il des lanceurs
d'alert
c'est comme tout c'est à dire que
bon d'abord
certaine manière
pense que c'est le sens de l'histoire
c'est à dire que la transparence
s'impose et donc la transparence ça
permet
j'imagine que la sphère orpea a pas
parlé et dû avoir un lanceur dalet c'est
pas devenu enfin je sais pas comment
c'est venu donc c'est un rôle utile ça
va dans le bon sens après c'est comme
tout il faut pas qu'ils soient rémunérés
il faut pas qu'il fasse ça pour de
l'argent et fait parce qu'il fasse ça
pour de la publicité il ya eu des
dérives mais comme tout mais
fondamentalement quelles dérives
il ya des cas je puis les noix en tête
de gens qui ont été rémunérés pour par
les médias par ça et là évidemment le
témoignage devient un peu plus compliqué
écoutez je suis pas le je me souviens
pas mais je peux vous dire que c'est
arrivé bon
comme bouchehr comme vous allez dire
comme tout individu normal il ya un
pourcentage de gens malhonnêtes dans
toutes les professions y compris chez
les patrons ouais je veux bien ah oui il
a été méchant avec vous il ya un pas été
chercher une petite mousse
puisque là c'est leur nom c'est oui
c'est l'heure
de la mouche vous dire vous le secret
les affaires il en pense quoi
alors là c'est le dilemme absolue parce
que les ong sont contre le secret des
affaires donc la transparence absolue
c'est que la transparence absolue
ça profite à qui alors évidemment et
éventuellement aux ong qui vivent 10 ne
vous fait pas assez d'impôts dans tel ou
tel pays mais évidemment ça profite aux
concurrents et comme les chinois
évidemment n'ont pas de secrets d'état
ont le secret des affaires absolue
publie rien quand il publie c'est pas
toujours des chiffres qui sont juste
comme les américains n'ont pas cette loi
c'est un dilemme absolue parce que moi
je comprends ne certaine manière la
demande de transparence mais si on est
les seuls à se [__] en short pour
reprendre votre expression favorite
quand tous les autres expressions
favorites mois s'est pendu haut et court
en tout cas comme on est les seuls
européens ou français à avoir ce type de
régulation en tout cas en discuter c'est
un régal pour les concurrents du monde
entier puisque effectivement ils vont
voir que telle boîte française ou
européenne d'ailleurs fait tant de
chiffre d'affaires dans tel pays emploie
de tant de personnes dont qui saisit à
baby là ça marche bien je vais y aller
ou au contraire là ça marche mal je vais
pas y aller donc c'est un c'est un
dilemme absolue parce qu'en même temps
ne trouve pas nos concitoyens nous oui
les gens qui votent voilà les parties
prenantes ont envie de cette
transparence donc c'est très compliqué
question un peu provoc de hulu faut-il
interdire les dividendes pour permettre
de rémunérer les salariés qui produisent
toute la richesse
mais je pensais que ça viendrait plutôt
les dividendes
et il faut bien travailler le steak et
dont les dividendes c'est quoi ces loyer
de l'argent vous investissez de l'argent
dans une entreprise et vos payer un
loyer la différence avec un loyer c'est
qu'il ya des années on vous paye pas
ça c'est la première chose l'appartement
peut brûler ou le studio peut brûler
parce que la boîte peut faire faillite
et puis à des années on vous paye
beaucoup bon la moyenne juste pour
donner un chiffre la moyenne des
dividendes je crois que c'est sur les
trois dernières années bon
j'ai fait une bêtise ou vos internautes
ne corrigeons ces 2 8% donc le rendement
du dividende vous avez une action qui
vaut 100 devient 8% c'est moins que les
loyers à paris
ces quatre ports sont à peu près à les
louer à paris c'est pas la france oui
mais en moyenne l'immobilier doit être
entre 3 et 4% donc ce que j'ai passé que
le dividende d'une action
il est moins rentable entre guillemets
qu investir dans l'immobilier
donc à partir de là soit on veut une
économie de marché on veut des capitaux
moi j'étais entrepreneur il a bien fait
que je trouve de l'argent pour investir
on veut des capitalistes qui
investissent qui prennent harris des
actionnaires et on les rémunèrent il
accepte le risque de pas être rémunéré
mais ils veulent un rendement ou alors
on dit bah non c'est une économie
nationaliser donc on va faire autrement
et à ce moment là d'ailleurs il ya des
systèmes qui existent un sens sans
dividende il ya les mutuelles il ya les
scop ça existe et d'ailleurs en france
on a la chance d'avoir tous ces systèmes
en compétition alors par exemple tous
les marchés mais des scop y en a je
crois 2000 à peu près est ce que vous
voyez comment c'est un droit de vote des
salariés grosso modo
ça paye pas de dividende y'a pas
d'actionnaire et gens sont heureux je
suis côté je ne sais pas s'ils sont plus
heureux ou moins auriez jamais eu de
comparaison de deux meneurs du salarié
serait ce serait peut-être intéressant
de faire ça ouais vous savez on a fait
un sondage la poste coville qui était
vraiment intéressant on expliqué chez
qui c'est qui non je peux combien
milliers de français l'ifop machin ce
cas on est au plus haut depuis 40 ans
sur l'image des entreprises donc bon je
veux bien entendre que l'entreprise
c'est l'enfer c'est comme toute
organisation humaine il ya des mamans
semés sur la gueule les intérêts sont
pas toujours les mêmes
les petites parenthèses d'ailleurs on
dit souvent salariés contre ces
questions de votre internaute salariés
contre actionnaires mais vous publiez
qu'il ya deux autres parties prenantes
dans cette affaire pour le partage du
profit et à l'état qui prend sa part et
l clients quand vous avez un gain de
productivité est ce que vous redonnez en
prix aux clients en baissant les prix ou
est-ce que vous augmentez al'inverse
quand les prix augmentent je vois qu'il
ya votre conseiller com qui fait du café
ah bon bah il a droit
question question internet bonjour
pouvez vous expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui un grand patron gagne 2 800
à 1000 fois plus qu'un certain vide
parmi les a pas beaucoup mais pourquoi
il ya une beaucoup plus parce que quand
vous avez un bon patron
vous avez un bon patron il est capable
de transformer l'entreprise quand carlos
tavares patron 100 is a
repris pessah en 2009 ne trompe pas la
boîte faisait
20 % du chiffre d'affaires actuel était
quasiment au bord du dépôt de bilan il a
transformé sa il a fusionné avec fiat
qui lie à map et gagne je pas combien de
fois mais certainement deux cent mille
fois plus que le footballeur de division
d'honneur ou de
du club amateur donc le talent ça se
rémunère alors évidemment
c'est pas la même chose qu'un
footballeur parce que tout le monde a
joué au football personnes a été patron
pas pour tout le monde n'a pas été
patron donc la capacité à analyser et à
accepter le talent d'un patron elle
n'est pas répandue donc voila mais c'est
un marché comme un marché des
footballeurs et donc
ils rémunérés la différence du mans à sa
défense le feu lorsque s'y joue mal il
est viré le patron il est viré et il ya
de plus en plus la durée de vie des
patrons des grandes entreprises se
raccourcit toute vitesse je crois que
ces cinq ou six ans maintenant pas durée
de vie par non pour être plus précis pas
la durée dit mais la durée de mandat la
durée où il son patron vous investissez
dans cours en ce moment
dans plein de choses je viens d'investir
dans une samson c'est pas un conseil
c'est pas pour non non non non non je ne
donne par ag vers la dhr de donner des
conseils parce que s'il ya bien un truc
qui est compliqué c'est d'investir donc
je serai loin de donner des conseils
investir sur le patron il faut investir
sur la boîte
enfin si vous devez choisir faut plus
investir sur l'entrepreneur que sur le
projet parce que dans plein de cas le
projet final par on parle là de juges
suppose de deux projets tout au début
dans beaucoup de cas le projet final est
un est très différent ou assez différent
de ce que le le l'entreprise avait
imaginé après dans quoi j'investis
j'avais je viens d'investir je crois que
ça on a signé hier dans une boîte qui
vais cei de faire à ces moments
longshot comme on dit qui va essayer de
faire des protéines de lait sans lait
animal
avec les vaches
sont qu'une source oui comme vous dites
enfin geste elle c'est ignoble que des
internes ne voit pas mais il a fait un
geste assez significatif donc
oui donc kiki c'est un problème dans la
planète avec le méthane est donc essayer
de trouver quelque chose qui arrive à
faire des pointes de l'est qui
permettent de faire des des produits
aussi mon moi j'aime le fromage
et donc voilà c'est un peu un dilemme
j'investis pas mal dans le vélo cargo
est ce que celle vélo cargo
partant du principe qu'on pourra plus
circuler avec des véhicules thermiques
et même que le vélo va être
comprimées le roi du centre ville et
donc pour les livraisons il faut trouver
l'équivalent un peu delà de la
camionnette en quelque sorte du van
voilà après qu'elle sert dans le tuk-tuk
oui enfin c'est une version un peu
modernisée du touquet un mot des moteurs
électriques etc les moteurs et cris de
zizou permet de faire des choses
intéressantes il faut faire les stages
d'entreprise ou les stages de cohésion
d'entreprise à madagascar ou ou façon
madagascar c'est à dire qu'on allait
gascard parce qu ils font beaucoup avec
pas grand chose est ce que nos
entreprises doit se doivent se préparer
à se faire tirer en disait est ce que
vous salariés doivent se préparer à se
faire tirer remet en disait
je sèche un peu sur cette question
et que l'intruse plus de sobriété dans
nos comportements en général y compris
dans l'entreprise je pense que c'est
celle à venir on est arrivé quand même
un peu un excès ne pas citer le kiwi
nous les landes toute la journée mais
voyez a failli à un moment où tout tout
de suite
bon c'est peut-être pas la bonne
solution mais de là à ce jeu parce que
j'avais besoin d'un tiers non disait
mémé
se faire vraiment déclassé cercle les
pays du tiers-monde vous nous rattraper
un tout petit peu et nous on va les
rattraper mais dans l'autre sens ah oui
enfin donc régressé je pensais c'était
pendant lequel je coupe comprenez ça
d'une autre manière c'est madagascar
mais un peu un peu perturbé comme
référence soit ils sont très très forts
pour ça ouais moi j'y étais il ya 20 ans
backpacker je me souviens pas très bien
de jouer j'ai pu je peux pas garder un
souvenir quelqu'un de très bons
souvenirs mais de touristes
oui enfin on est en compétition avec de
plus en plus de pays c'est ça le est-ce
que la course éperdue non je le redis je
crois pas je moi je on s'est peut-être
comment dire le tropisme positive d'un
entrepreneur mais moi je me lève pas le
matin pour partir battus quoi je pense
pas que ce soit la majorité du
comportement des entreprises est ce que
la course est difficile oui est ce que
la compétition est difficile oui est ce
que il ya de plus en plus de commandes
de pays qu'on attendait pas oui bien sûr
donc voilà il faut que la france arrive
à produire assez de champion assez
d'entreprises qui croise voilà oui c'est
un vrai sujet doit-on taxer les robots
n'ont elles je comprends l'idée parce
qu'au fond on peut dire et les emplois
sont remplacés par des robots il faut
bien qu'ils cotisent
sauf que on s'aperçoit c'est vrai pour
l'allemagne que plus un pays robotisés
puis il ya des emplois créés parce qu'on
gagne en productivité on investit et ont
fait croître l'entreprise donc c'est la
fausse bonne idée
est-ce que vous avez trois livres à nous
conseiller
est-ce que j'ai troisième à gouazé je
pourrais être bon je vais le faire quand
même un très bon livre que j'ai écrit
s'appelle l'intendance suivra ou par
exister sur de gaulle et l'économie
après
trois que vous avez lu ouais après leurs
moyens un livre que j'ai beaucoup lu
j'ai eu plusieurs fois qui
je l'évoqué tout à l'heure c'est liberté
capitaliste de milton friedman parce que
finalement il définit une certaine
manière un concept philosophique y ait
la liberté politique liberté économique
et qui était moi qui m'a fasciné à 18
ans et que j'ai relu dernièrement et je
me suis dit que
ce que vous avez fait l'essec vous avez
fait l'essec ouais j'ai fait l'essai
quel rapport qu'est ce que vous pensez
d'hayek
il fait partie des penseurs économiques
intéressants après il est un peu dérivé
sur le tard si j'ose dire de même que
friedman sur la fin de sa carrière un
peu dérivé quoi mais c'est pas parce que
il a eu des opinions que je partage pas
sur la fin de sa vie que pour autant je
n'y arrivais pas voilà il n'est pas
conduire à remettre en cause quoi le
doute bouquin le dernier que j'ai lu
c'est l'armée fantôme en anglais gosses
fleet dans la flotte fantôme pardon qui
est très intéressant ça nous donne
géostratégique qui vous passionnera
en gros la chine attaque faire une
espèce de pearl harbor enfin moi je peux
vous raconter beaucoup enfin en gros
c'est sûr
c'est très orienté sur la marine les
enjeux maritimes qui a un sujet très
ignoré dans ce pays mais enfin qui est
un sujet très important
et voilà mais après je pense que les
bouquins parce que c'est un sujet très
important
parce que je pense que l'économie du
xxème siècle sera maritime les flux
deux bateaux les flux fallait flux de
marchandises pardon pas seront
majoritairement par mer parce que la
france
alors l'oubli les français le savent pas
mais on a le deuxième domaine maritime
mondial
grâce aux territoires d'outre-mer
que ce sont des ressources qu'il faut
exploiter habilement mais qui sont des
ressources importantes et qu'au fond
nous on est un peuple de paysans pas un
peuple de marins enfin historiquement
depuis on pas remonté à trafalgar et
autres mets donc je trouve qu'on sous
estime le potentiel et qu'on s'intéresse
pas assez à ce sujet là le seul
d'ailleurs offrir que je le cite le seul
qui a un
composante maritime
dans son programme c'est jean luc
mélenchon
ça me fait rire non mais parce que ne
s'est pas complètement évident que le
parisien du medef met en avant jean luc
mélenchon comme comme référence sera
peut-être temps
que pense-t-il du bic quit aux states
alors dans le bec oui tiens c'est quoi
le but mais quid c'est les millions
d'américains qui ont pigé dit il serait
temps pour jouer c'est une boutade on
est apolitique
oui le big witz et les millions
d'américains qui ont quitté marché du
travail je parlais du taux d'emploi tout
le taux d'emploi aux états unis il est
plus bas après la crise qu avant alors
qu'en france celle inverse il faut
comprendre qu'il ya une grande partie
très grande partie de ces gens là qui
ont pris leur retraite pourquoi parce qu
aux us comme vous le savez la retraite
c'est la capitalisation se taire c'est
vous c'est l'argent que vous avez mis de
côté dans un système défiscalisées or
comme la bourse la dernier a pris 30%
vous êtes en nombre de gens qui ont
vu qu'avec le patrimoine qui avaient
augmenté il pouvait prendre leur
retraite plus tôt que ce qu'ils
pensaient donc ça c'est plus le
pourcentage mais une partie importante
après on a moins protégés aux états unis
toute l'économie de services
restauration tous ces emplois là il ya
eu moins dead qu'en europe et qu'en
france du coup il est plus de faillites
du coup il ya plein de jeunes qui ont
disparu et ces gens là bas ils sont par
kasab le
directement dans l'industrie parce que
voilà vous improvisez pas j'en sais rien
soudeur ou
après il ya un phénomène qu'on voit
aussi en france dans les conventions
beaucoup moindre c'est des gens qui
disent bien mais moi je suis resté chez
moi
j'ai plus envie de bosser comme ça j'ai
plus envie de ce métier un convoi dans
la restauration beaucoup ont choisi
d'unir les grosses difficultés qu'ont
les restaurants restaurants les hôtels
les restaurants beaucoup à à recruter du
personnel ont monté les seniors beaucoup
avaient besoin de jouer alors ok on va
augmenter les salaires là il ya eu une
négociation qui augmentent tous les
minima branche de 16% bon ok mais le
point bon ça résout pas tout mais ça
fait venir des gens le problème c'est
que ça veut dire que l'addition va
augmenter de 16% alors pas tout à fait
puisque restauration le coût du
personnel ça dépend des demandes entre
le mac do et le machin mais le coût du
personnel c'est 70% l'addition à peu
près en moyenne donc ça va augmenter de
70% de 16% c'est pas 12 un truc comme ça
bon et donc qu'est ce qui va se passer
est ce que le client va accepter ce
trust est ce que c'est pour ça que les
augmentations de salaires c'est
compliqué parce qu'il ya directement un
effet sur le prix est encore la
restauration n'est pas en concurrence
internationale si on parlait de
l'industrie l'a immédiatement vous avez
le produit
chinois en tout cas étrangers qui n'a
pas eu cette augmentation de salaire et
qui devient plus compétitif
qu'est ce que vous pensez je reformule
la question
il est quelques patrons français
d'industrie détenteurs de monopole de
médias dominants en france il en pense
quoi le medef alors les quelques patrons
d'industrie a pensé à bolloré arnault
niel et s'est
dit maman qui a pas de monopole
justement près et de questions il y as
qu'il ya de monopole des médias non vous
en est d'ailleurs la preuve est ce que
l'information est libre dans ce pays oui
après
je veux dire chacun est libre de trouver
les actionnaires qui peut or il se
trouve que c'est effectivement des
médias qui perdent de l'argent la
plupart du temps et que donc c'est des
actionnaires qui ont les poches pleines
qui acceptent de perdre de l'argent sont
philanthrope venant et sont pas
philanthropes ils pensent acheter une
influence je doute non mais je doute je
doute
il faut demander aujourd'hui c'est un
mais je doute six journalistes un nom
mais il faut demander aux gens lisent
pas à vous aux journalistes de ses
journaux en tout cas quand vous voyez le
monde
je pense pas que niel et des articles ou
en joueurs sur lui dans le monde va
jouer honnêtement j'ai pas regardé de
près question de gros bain que
pense-t-il du pantouflage des politique
de la haute administration française 2
que pense-t-il du pantouflage des
politiques il régule de la haute
administration française vers les
grandes entreprises françaises du cac 40
comme edouard philippe chez à tous
vas le mot pantouflage tout de suite
connaught la question
si vous préférez des politiques qu'ils
fassent de la politique toute leur vie
et qui ne travaillent jamais dans le
privé c'est un choix je pense que c'est
une erreur moi je préfère à des gens qui
travaillent et qui fait de la politique
qui reviennent dans le privé qui font de
la politique y aurait près après je
suppose que dans la question il ya
est-ce que vous m'en dire dans ses
fonctions précédentes il a pu aider
telle entreprise chez qui ils iraient et
ça il ya un comité de déontologie je
promets s'appelle une taille et un truc
qui existe qui pour les hauts
fonctionnaires en tout cas vérifie que
la personne en question ont pas eu à
traiter le dossier de l'entreprise en
question donc il faut trouver le bon
équilibre mais moi je veux pas je veux
pas je crois pas que ça soit sain
d'avoir des puisqu'on a eu d'ailleurs
pendant pendant trente ans des
politiciens professionnels
non il ya quand même des gens qu'on fait
des allers-retours j'ai pas cité de noms
mais il ya des gens qui font des allers
retours massifs peut citer annonce qu'
il n'est pas en france thierry breton
il a été patron d'une entreprise
patron de france télécom je crois avant
il a fait était ministre entre les deux
je me suis un peu plus exactement de son
parcours me dire moi je trouve pas ça
sain d'avoir des gens en politique qui
soit en politique à 18 ans et qu'il soit
jusqu'à 65 ans
question internet que pense-t-il du
haras de licorne française que nous
constitue bien heureux mozart de la
finance macron levée de fonds égale
richesse
le haras de licorne n'allait pas
mauvaise et bon c'est plutôt une bonne
chose on va pas pleurer après tout ce
que j'ai dit sur le fait qu' on n'avait
pas de champion de la tactique en avait
des monopoles mac après est ce que
toutes ces licorne vont devenir des
champions européens ou des champions
mondiaux non
mais il suffit qu'il y en a
quelques-unes c'est là le monde de latex
et hyper darwinien il faut avoir sans
moteur de recherche qui démarre en
californie dans les années 90 pour au
final avoir un google
et entre temps il ya eu plein de morts
donc il y aura des morts dans ces
licorne et
il y aura et enfin des morts des boîtes
qui vont pas qu'ils vont pas générer le
rebelle enfin la valorisation d'un
couple est présente mais mais je pense
que c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pardon pour l'écosystème
et pour le pays est ce que vous voulez
qu'on aborde un sujet en particulier
non on a fait un bon tour mais vous de
me dire ou es ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose qui va
rester impérissable sur les réseaux
impérissable sûrement pas non je
compare les déclinistes tout à l'heure
moi je vois pas du déclin non mais je
veux d'expliquer il faut se méfier de la
barbarie qui revient à grand pas
je passe ya un point que la question
mais moi je suis une optimiste et je
suis un patriote
donc
en tout cas pour ceux qui aiment leur
pays je trouve ça en france on peut
aller faire des études on peut aller
faire tout ce que vous voulez mais c'est
en france qu'il faut tenter sa chance on
est quand même dans un monde où la tech
donne plein d'opportunités donc moi je
trouve que c'est
il faut pas avoir peur de se lancer des
choux et de continuer et d'une certaine
manière je le dire comme ça moi quand je
vois des gens j'ai encore fait un
interview de recrutement lapointe poste
de directeur général dans une de mes
boîtes je vois un gars qui a monté une
boîte et qui a planté à sa bonne plutôt
envie de recruter américaine pardon à
l'américaine ouais je partage pas toutes
les valeurs de américain one là mais je
trouve que cette idée de dire l'échec
vous rend plus fort bien pu ne pas
commander à une banalité est assez vrai
parce que le mec a pris un risque il a
essayé il en a pardon devient comme ça
il en a chié il a été au bout du truc et
puis je vois bien parce que c'est comme
temps comme quand on est tout seul et
que ça marche pas et qu'on ait tout seul
et qu'on a et qu'on a
la licorne tout va bien mais voilà c'est
pas la majorité de l'espace comme disait
audiard donc je trouve qu'ils voient là
il faut
il faut essayer de il faut tenter sa
chance quand je vois roux de bézieux
merci merci à vous
[Musique]
e
com
[Musique]
e